Das war jetzt nur die kurze Response auf den Slack.
Dürfen wir den Chat nennen oder wie nennen wir den jetzt? Slack?
Das ist jetzt auch...
Du meinst, in den Schleck...
Nee, was ich geil fand an Allo war, dass zwei meiner Android-begeisterten Kollegen halt das sofort runterladen wollten. Und dann der eine, hm, das sieht irgendwie gar nicht so aus wie das, was sie in der Keynote hatten. Da hat es doch tatsächlich Google nicht geschafft, einen Namen zu wählen, unter dem nicht schon ein Messenger in ihrem eigenen Playstore ist.
Oder jemand anders war schneller.
Ach, den müssen sie erstmal weglagen.
Ja, vor drei Jahren.
Das NPM-Gate von Google.
Vor drei Jahren oder so? Also ein relativ altes Teil.
Also unsere KI hat uns gesagt, da ist noch frei.
Was mir so ein bisschen auf der ganzen Spracherkennung fehlt, ist, wenn man mal wieder die Probleme mit seinen Handgelenken hat als Entwickler. Ich hätte ganz gerne Sprachsteuerung für meine IDI in der Tat. Ja, also ich meine, das ist mir echt auf die Nerven gegangen. Ich konnte in der Woche kaum coden und was kannst du da machen? Nichts außer Hände stillhalten. Das fehlt noch so ein bisschen, wobei es auch natürlich... Nee, ich bin aus dem Urlaub wieder gekommen und habe in der Tat von meiner Handhaltung beim Coden Probleme bekommen, also beidseitig vor allem. Das war nicht so schön. Also ich habe in der Tat auch da gar nicht so viel im Bett gelümmelt und diese typischen Abknickbewegungen gemacht, das war von ganz normalen Coden.
Wenn die KI richtig gut ist, dann setzt du dich vor deinen Rechner und sagst...
Und guck sie so lange an, bis mein Rechner von alleine weiß, dass ich Coden will. Großartig!
Nee, aber ich meine, wenn das Ding klug ist, dann sagst du halt so was wie schreib mir ein Programm, das mir sagt, wo in vier Tagen das beste Wetter ist und wo ich langfahren muss.
Und wie ich erstmal den günstigsten Flug dahin bekomme.
Naja, also ich wäre jetzt noch nicht mal so überrascht. Würden wir da nicht irgendwie auch bald hinkämen. Also es kann schon sein, dass dieses ganze Programmieren, was ja im Prinzip auch nichts ein... Ich meine Programmieren heißt, ich sag meinem Computer, was ich gerne möchte, was er für mich tut. Und letzten Endes ist halt Butter über Amazon stellen auch nichts anderes.
Du vergleichst automatisierten Codeschreiben mit Butter bestellen bei Amazon.
Na da steckt schon eine relativ komplexe Logistik dahinter. Da müssen auch diverse Routen gelöst werden und so. Also ja, insbesondere wenn sie das jetzt hier in Berlin innerhalb von zwei Stunden bringen wollen.
Aber das ist ein interessanter Gedanke. Also wer bringt denn die erste Sprache mit Syntax raus, die darauf optimiert ist, dass du sie per Spracheingabe dem Rechner beibringst? Weil ich meine, vor, Klammer auf, i gleich, Semikolon, Klammer zu, geschweifte Klammer auf, nächste Zeile, also das geht ja nicht.
Das geht das nicht, das muss man schon sprachlich erklären. Das hier bitte zwölfmal, außer wenn das und ansonsten aber das, also eher so.
Na das hat ja Apple mit AppleScript schon probiert.
Ja und sind damit ganz schön auf dem Bauch gelandet.
Ja, weil man das eintippen muss, aber wenn man das jetzt nur noch einspricht.
Weißt du aber, wann ich gerade denken muss an dieses 11.
Ja das stimmt, das kommt immer wieder gut.
Das massive Problem an AppleScript war ja, dass es keine greifbare Syntax hatte. Also du hattest dann so in und off und so weiter, das konnte man irgendwie wahllos einstreuen und dann, naja, naja, nee.
Wollen wir mal reinhören?
Oh bitte.
Schon wieder?
Haben wir schon fünf Mal gehabt, oder?
Das kann man doch nicht oft genug hören.
Das ist so großartig. Ich sehe gerade, wir hatten das schon vor zwei Sendungen, kann das sein? Wir haben das vor zwei Sendungen schon mal gespielt.
Geht nicht.
Schiebt doch erstmal das Fenster rüber und macht dann den Doppelklick.
Ich hab gerade versucht, als ich das Fenster mit diesem Ding auf einen anderen Bildschirm schieben wollte, dass es an der Stelle irgendwie kaputt gegangen ist. Aber wir hatten das schon. Ihr wisst alle, was wir meinen. Eleven, irgendwie der Fahrstuhl, ist das einfach grandios.
It don't do Scottish accent. Die Idee wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
So, das war also Home und Hallo.
Hallo.
Hallo. Mach mal den Schlecks-Get wieder an.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Und dann gab's ja noch... Remote Code Execution as a Service? Na, diese in kleine Teile aufgeteilten Android-Anwendungen, die du per Link starten kannst?
Ähm, Instant Apps.
Instant Apps, so hieß es.
Ja, also was denkst du darüber?
Gewagt denke ich darüber.
Also ich war ein bisschen überrascht, muss ich sagen. Weil es in gewisser Hinsicht erstmal gar nicht wie so eine doofe Idee klang.
Aber gefühlt...
Die Marketingbranche dreht gerade durch, deswegen schreibt da einer, ja, war bei uns in der Firma auch so.
Nee, klar, weil natürlich diese Apps haben natürlich Vorteile gegenüber Webseiten. Haben wir nun alle schon tausendmal durch. Ist so. Du kannst da einfach effizienteren Code schreiben, kannst irgendwie Sensoren benutzen, all diese ganzen Mumpets. Und du möchtest halt gerne eigentlich für alles eine App haben. Aber du lädst ja natürlich für jeden... Das Ding muss erst leuchten, dann musst du niesen.
Wir schneiden doch raus.
Klar, sicher. Also man will halt eigentlich für alles eine App haben. Also nicht unbedingt immer, aber oft ist es sinnvoller.
Aber immer öfter.
Oder attraktiver, sag ich mal. Ob das sinnvoller ist, da mal dahingestellt. Das ist irgendwie so. Nur, gerade wenn du halt irgendwas zugeschickt bekommst, mal eben mit hier guck dir mal das Video an, la la la, buch mal was, kauf mal was, etc. Dann hast du es dann doch eher halt mit... Viel besser denn. Hast du es mit Webseiten zu tun und so weiter. Google's Idee ist jetzt, ja, wir liefern euch quasi On-Demand auf Basis einer URL gleich die App mit aus.
Ja, aber eben nicht die ganze App. Also das ist ja noch der Trick da dran.
Genau, nicht unbedingt die ganze App, sondern eben so irgendwie ihre Bestandteile zusammenmodularisiert. Nur das, was eben jetzt für den jeweiligen Kontext erforderlich ist. Wobei, wenn man sich glaube ich nicht so viel Illusionen machen sollte, da ist dann wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch ganz schön was runterzuladen. Also die Appgrößen wirklich richtig, richtig klein zu kriegen. Keine Ahnung, wie weit das mit den Development Tools unter Android mittlerweile kein Problem darstellt. Klingt auf jeden Fall sehr nach dem, was wir auch von Apple in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren gesehen haben, mit dieser ganzen Modularisierung, die Lizenz beim Installieren nicht mehr das runter, was du überhaupt brauchst.
Ja, aber es ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, noch mal so, dass du tatsächlich die App...
Also auf Funktionalitäten noch mal runtergebrochen bist.
Genau, dass die App in mehrere Module aufgeteilt wird, die, wenn die alle geladen sind, hast du eine komplette App. Und wenn du nur irgendeinen Deep Link aufrufst, dann landest du in einem der Module und dann wird nur das Modul runtergeladen.
Ja, und interessanterweise meinten sie auch noch, das ganze sogar noch, glaube ich, bis Android KitKat rückwirkend machen zu können.
Ach herrje, genau.
Aber das geht natürlich alles nur wieder mit Google, Play Store. Also das ist jetzt kein Android an sich Feature, sondern es ist eben diese Google Version von Android.
Diese Play Store Services, wie es so schön heißt, das ist ja sowieso jetzt der Weg von Google, ja genau, Updates über das System zu bügeln, wo sie halt von den Telefonherstellern reinweise hängen gelassen werden. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch der richtige Weg. Also wenn du es halt nicht schaffst, irgendwie einen Samsung dazu zu bringen, innerhalb von Tagen das Update zu bringen, sondern das wir in den letzten Jahren brauchen, dann musst du halt irgendwie sowas machen.
Also da bin ich mal gespannt. Das war natürlich auch alles wieder latest this year. Das will ich erstmal funktionieren sehen. Aber es hat die Frage, wie das so mit der User-Expectation so ist. Da kommt halt dann irgendwie was ein. Was sagst du gerade am Anfang?
Remote Code Execution is a Service.
Ja gut, stimmt schon. Aber wenn die App halt signiert und im Store akkreditiert ist, ist es ja an sich kein anderer Vorgang.
Ja, im Prinzip schon. Aber die Hürde ist natürlich höher, wenn du zu irgendeinem Store navigieren musst und da auf installieren drücken musst. Dann musst du warten, bis es installiert ist. Das ist halt eine andere Hürde, als wenn du irgendwo auf einen Link klickst und dann wird der Code ausgefüllt.
Das ist schon klar. Also wenn man davon ausgeht, dass viel Software kompromittiert ist und mit Malweiler herkommt, dann ist natürlich jetzt sozusagen das Problem noch vergrößert worden.
Oder wenn man davon ausgeht, dass es als potenzieller Malware-Entwickler relativ einfach ist, ohne einen tiefer gehenden Review im Google Play Store zu landen.
Sondern nur auf Basis einer URL?
Also ich weiß ja nicht, wie der Review-Prozess jetzt bei Google ist, aber der scheint ja so relativ sehr, sehr dünn zu sein. Also nicht, dass ich den von Apple verteidigen möchte, ganz im Gegenteil, aber vom Sicherheitsaspekt her ist es glaube ich relativ einfach, eine Software in den Play Store zu kriegen, die etwas tut, von der Google sicherlich nicht will, dass sie auf dem System das tut, was sie tut.
Oder wo sie zumindest nicht ausreichend Interesse daran zeigen, das zu verhindern.
Nee, wo sie schon Interesse hätten, nur sie tun es nicht, weil es kein entsprechendes Review gibt. Also das ist so, das sehe ich halt ein bisschen kritisch, weil du musst halt als derjenige, der die Malware in den Store stellt, halt nicht mehr eine Remote Code Execution finden, sondern du wirst auf dem Device ausgeführt und musst jetzt eigentlich nur noch einen Weg finden aus der Sandbox, die da natürlich vorhanden ist, auszubrechen. Und vor allen Dingen bieten sich natürlich auch ganz, ganz neue, schöne Dinge. Also ich meine, so Cross-Site-Scripting gab es halt in nativen Apps bis jetzt nicht. Aber was passiert denn nun, wenn du tatsächlich dieses Deep-Linking in eine App zur Methode machst und alle Apps jetzt plötzlich die Links, die sie bekommen, irgendwie interpretieren und darauf irgendwas tun und dann gerne mal...
Aber diesen Mechanismus gibt es schon.
Ja, natürlich gibt es den Mechanismus.
Mit dem Unterschied, die App muss bereits installiert sein.
Genau, genau, genau.
Was jetzt noch mit dazu kommt, ist, dass mit dem Link auch gleich die App noch dazukommt. Und das im Idealfall noch in zusammengeschnittener Variante. Die da ja dann nach einem, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist es ja auch so, die sind ja nicht nur instant installiert, sondern die sind ja auch instant wieder deinstalliert. Also du benutzt sie sozusagen für einen bestimmten Zeitraum und dann sind sie wieder weg. Aber sie machen sich Gedanken.
Nee, also ich finde es ein spannendes Konzept, aber ich halte es halt für sehr gefährlich. Also da werden wir sicherlich dann interessanten Spaß am Gerät sehen, denke ich mal. So Security Nightmares auf dem Kongress und so, das wird sicherlich spannend.
Ja, sonst noch was passiert auf der? ja gut, dann mal halt noch so dieses, jenes, Android, hier Framework, 3D, diese ganzen VR-Wahnsinne und so weiter.
Haben sie jetzt gesagt, wie das heißen soll, das neue Android, tatsächlich Nutella?
Na ja, sie meinten, das Internet soll doch mal was mit N vorschlagen, ein N-Wort. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf so eine Idee kommen kann.
Ist doch ganz einfach.
Das muss doch mit N anfangen.
Wann war die Google IO.?
Das klingt wie so ein negrianischer Spam-Scam-Name.
Vor einer Woche ungefähr, ja.
Weil der Aktienkurs ist seitdem hochgegangen.
Von was? Von Google oder von Alphabet? Na gut, ich meine die naheliegenden Witze müssen wir gar nicht wiederholen auf jeden Fall. Du suchst das Endwort. Letty, ich sollte dich noch irgendwie an Java erinnern.
Ich bin letztens gesucht, was so die beliebtesten Programmiersprachen sind und durch den ganzen Android-Hype ist natürlich dein heiß geliebtes Java wieder hochgesprungen. Und so gesehen, grad auch auf GitHub, was die Projekte angeht, dass Java...
ist voll im Kommen.
Voll im Kommen.
Haben sie sich Google jetzt mit Urakel schon geeinigt oder noch nicht?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ne, die streiten sich noch über...
Neun Zeilen Code oder so?
Ja, Code und auch generell geht es halt auch so unterschwellig einfach um diese Frage, ob APIs generell eigentlich Copyright-geistiges Eigentum...
Copyrightbar sind oder nicht?
Wo es ja in den USA so eine Tendenz dazu gibt, das sozusagen so zu bewerten durch die Gerichte. Da stecke ich jetzt nicht zu sehr drin. Wir hatten das irgendwie jetzt Montag bei Logbook Netzpolitik auch mal etwas unwissend diskutiert. Weiß nicht, die haken sich da halt.
Loias gonna loi oder so.
Das war es jetzt schon mit Java. Also Java ist populär, aber zu sagen.
Ja, es hat mich erschrocken, weil ich nämlich auch nicht gedacht hätte, dass sie noch so gut im Kommen sind und habe diese Android-Schiene so vergessen.
Android und vor allen Dingen auch Backend, also es gibt halt verdammt viel Enterprise-Backend-Zeug. Das wird sehr sehr gerne und viel in Java gemacht.
Weil die auch eine ziemlich gute Anbindung an die Postgres-Datenbank haben, wie ich gelernt habe, an diese reine Sprache, diese Postgres-SQL-Sprache.
Ja, Leute geben die immer noch MySQL in großem Maßstab benutzen.
Ja, also klar, das werden wir so schnell nicht wieder los. Aber das ist klar, das ist halt irgendwie das Cobol.
Es sei denn, es kommt was offensichtlich Besseres um die Ecke.
Das Cobol des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Ja, das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu gemein. Na ja, es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte sich Cobol irgendwie seit 30 Jahren irgendwie weiterentwickelt, oder?
Ja, hat sich aber so weiterentwickelt.
Es gibt immer mal wieder eine Major Version. Sind es bei Java 8 oder so? Und hat auch einige interessante Features dazu bekommen?
Sagt das mal einer Apple, dass sie mal ihr iTunes mal auf Java 8 upgraden? Da warte ich schon lange drauf.
Seitwärts.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Frage von Compatibility. Und wahrscheinlich benutzen sie immer noch dieses Web-Objects?
Ich will es überhaupt nicht wissen.
Die benutzen irgendeinen Scheiß, den sie nicht so ohne Weiteres loswerden. Und ich hoffe nur, dass sie schon seit Langem daran arbeiten, das alles mal wegzuschmeißen, weil so geht es ja irgendwie gar nicht. Denn das verhindert den Fortschritt auch in der Mitte eben im Übrigen. Fortschritt habe ich übrigens gerade.
Goldene Überleitungsbrücken für 100.
Das ist nur so ein kleines Nebending, weil gerade als ich jetzt die letzte Sendung vor zwei Wochen veröffentlicht habe, war das Geschrei wieder groß und wie sich auch gezeigt hat, berechtigt, dass in dem Moment, wo ich halt eine Sendung veröffentlicht habe, mein Download-Server irgendwie ein unangemessenes Verhalten an den Tag gelegt hat.
War er unartig?
Ja, war unartig und ist auch ehrlich gesagt bis heute noch ein bisschen unklar. Das Ding lief halt in irgendeiner VM, die ich nicht so unter eigener Kontrolle hatte. Und hatte da noch ein Leithat, TPD, Laufen und zwar auch wie alles nicht so wohl konfiguriert. Und jetzt habe ich mal jemanden angelassen, der davon was versteht. Und unter anderem habe ich den Download-Server jetzt, der läuft jetzt unter Engines. Und außerdem ist es halt jetzt so ein Root-Server geworden. Also ich habe mir jetzt einfach mal so einen modernen Root-Server.
Engine X, aber egal.
Was auch immer das heißen soll. Man hätte sicher von vorne rein schöne Namen einfallen lassen können, aber die wollten das ja nicht. Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt so einen Root-Server, frisches FreeBSD drauf mit irgendwie 10.3 und mit zweimal SSD, zweimal Platte, mit jeweils ZFS, mit RAID 1, schön gemirror.
Da habe ich gleich mal eine Frage.
Bitte.
Zweimal Platte als Mürrer, zweimal SSD als Mürrer, aber nicht zusammengeklebt zu einem Stripe, oder?
Nee, einfach nur Mürrer.
Das heißt, du hast zwei Pools?
Genau. Und SSD-Kram ist halt so für alles, was irgendwie schneller Zugriff ist. Und die Platte ist so Medien-Dateien, wo es jetzt nicht unbedingt auf die SSD-Performance angeht, sondern mehr um die Menge an Daten, die ich da unterbringen kann. Das heißt, auf dem SSD-Kram ist halt so OS, und dann kommt dieser ganze PAP-Kram, das kommt da alles hin. Und die ganzen MP3s und MPAs und was ich da noch alles auf meinem Server rumliegen habe, das ist halt eine ganze Menge Holz mittlerweile. Ja, vor allem muss ich dann halt auch mal ein bisschen genauer gucken, was ich denn eigentlich so für Nachfrage habe, was denn so für Bandbreite benötigt wird. Und so genau kann ich das gar nicht beurteilen, weil sich bei dieser ganzen Analyse herausgestellt hat, dass das auch keine wirklich genaue Erfassung ist. Das war alles ein bisschen falsch konfiguriert, deswegen kann ich nur gerade so raten, aber die Meta-Ebene schmeißt vermutlich pro Monat so mit 20 Terabyte Daten um sich. Was schonmal ganz gut ist. Ich hab jetzt halt so einen Hetzner-Server, der hat halt 30 Terabyte mit drin. Und dann, wenn man halt drüber kommt, dann muss man jetzt auch nicht gleich beiahm werden. Dann kannst du dann irgendwie noch mal ein Terabyte für 1,40 Euro oder so was dazukaufen und dann bist du da auch aus dem Schneider. Also, wenn man das rechtzeitig dazukauft, weiß nicht so ganz genau, wie das mit den Automatiken ist. Das werd ich jetzt alles noch kennenlernen. Ja, und dann hab ich mir natürlich in dem Zusammenhang auch mal darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie man denn eigentlich so einen Download-Server haben will. Jetzt ist überhaupt erstmal die Grundfunktionalität hergestellt und jetzt könnt ihr ja mal gerne mal testen. Da kommen jetzt die Daten schon schneller. Dann hab ich noch das Double-Pay-Traffic-Bit gesetzt. Ihr wisst, was das ist. Das ist dieser Netzneutralitäts-Fail, den wir ja haben, dass die Telekom sich ja quasi dafür bezahlen lässt, dass Anbieter einen guten Zugang zu ihnen haben. Weil die ja meinen so, wir müssen nicht mit jedem pieren und wenn Hetzner einen geilen Link haben will zu uns, dann müsst ihr dafür bezahlen. Das tun sie dann auch. Und wenn du als Hetzner-Kunde diesen geilen Link zur Telekom auch benutzen willst, dann musst du halt auch dafür bezahlen. Du zahlst an Hetzner quasi einen Anteil von dem, was Hetzner an die Telekom zahlt. Na ja, Hetzner macht das aber aus politischen Gründen, um allen Leuten klar zu machen, wo hier das Problem ist. Das Feature heißt nämlich Double Paid Traffic. So heißt das dann. So bestellst du das, so steht das dann auf deiner Konsole.
Du glaubst doch nicht, dass die bei der Telekom gewissen haben, und weil das jetzt Double Paid Traffic heißt, die da irgendwas ändern werden.
Nein, aber es ist halt ein Beitrag zur politischen Diskussion um Netzneutralität, den sie an der Stelle äußern. Das kann ich von daher auch vollkommen nachvollziehen.
Naja, es ist auch so ein bisschen wie YouTube, als sie gesagt hat, die GEMA hat uns die Rechte für dieses Video nicht eingeräumt. Es ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen Fingerpointing dabei, so nach der Art, ja, wenn ihr das wollt, müsst ihr mehr bezahlen, aber es ist nicht unsere Schuld.
Ja gut, da ist das Fingerpointing aber in die falsche Richtung. Und in diesem Fall bei Hetzner, denke ich, mal geht es in die richtige Richtung. Also, ich meine, sie hätten es ja auch super high bandwidth, mega plus da Excellence Feature nennen können, haben sie aber nicht.
Mit einem magenten Hintergrund.
Hier zahlst du doppelt. Und das tue ich auch, das ist halt irgendwie nochmal 5 Euro obendrauf auf den ganzen Mumpets und so ist es dann halt. Aber dafür habe ich dann eben jetzt auch Bandbreite in die TDSL-Welt, weil es halt nicht irrelevant ist. Gut, also auch da dürften jetzt sozusagen die Kanäle geöffnet sein und ihr solltet alle demnächst eure Meter-Ebene-Dosis schneller bekommen.
Habst du auf dem Pool, wo dein OS drauf ist, hast du da auch Compression an?
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Geil, spart Platz und ist schneller.
Ja, aber nur wenn du Sachen hast, die sich auch komprimieren lassen.
Ja, sein OS.
Ach so, das OS, ja okay.
Ja, aber gerade weil er die Pools getrennt hat und deine Mediendaten, die brauchst du nicht komprimieren, da lohnt es nicht. Aber wenn du dein ganzes OS, PHP, das ganze Giraffe, das kannst du schön prima komprimieren. Und das Schöne an LZ4 ist, dass wenn es nicht komprimierbar ist, dann merkt das auch ziemlich schnell und hört auch sofort auf. Also selbst wenn du deine MPEGs komprimieren lassen würdest, würde es nicht viel stören, weil der testet kurz alles klar, das liegt nicht komprimieren und bricht ab. Also LZ4 kann man sozusagen eigentlich als Default betrachten, schon bei ZFS. Und das ist wirklich schneller, weil vorher hast du irgendwie, sagen wir mal, einen MB eingeladen. Das hat von Platte so und so lange gedauert. Jetzt lädst du nur noch ein halbes MB. Das lädt sich in der Hälfte der Zeit fest platten-technisch. Und die andere Hälfte brauchst du auf jeden Fall nicht zum Dekomprimieren, sondern nur noch so ein ganz bisschen davon. Das heißt, in Gesamten bist du halt tatsächlich schneller mit weniger Laden und Dekomprimieren als das gesamte Laden. Deswegen lohnt sich das. Und die Rechner heute sind schnell genug, dass sie das alles so ein Ei abfeuern.
Ja, klar, so ein Intel schockt das gar nicht.
Das stimmt, das kann man ja nachträglich einfach einschalten, ne?
Ja, dann ist das zwar alles noch nicht komprimiert, aber beim nächsten Update dann und so weiter und so fort, da wär das dann so. Also kann ich mir empfehlen.
Kann man mal machen. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt so viele Doppelungen da drin. Also ich werd doppelten Speed haben, allein schon dadurch, dass ich irgendwie SSDs auf einmal habe, wo vorher keine waren. Also der PAP-Kram ist noch nicht umgezogen. Das kommt jetzt im zweiten Schritt. Achso.
Na dann vorher LZ4 einschalten.
Auf jeden Fall. Die CPU wird schneller sein. Da ist mehr RAM. Das ist einfach schnellerer Architektur. Das ist schon mal alles doppelt so schnell. Dann hab ich irgendwie, dann setz ich auch auf PAP7. Das ist auch nochmal doppelt so schnell als das 5.6, was ich jetzt gerade verwende. Dann hab ich halt auch SSD-Rate. Auch alles noch mal potentiell doppelt so schnell.
Genau.
Also sind so viele Verdopplungen drin, dass ich mir fast gar nicht vorstellen kann, dass man dann noch durch das Einschalten eines solchen Features nochmal eine spürbare Verbesserung haben kann.
Spürbar wird den nicht sein, aber das wäre trotzdem blöd, das mitzumachen.
Wenn es nicht schadet, dann kann man das ja mal machen.
Und deine SSDs werden ja auch weniger belastet durch Schreibzugänge, weil sie einfach auch weniger schreiben müssen. Weil du hast ja dann auch inzwischen dann hier Trim und so. Wir benutzen ja auch bei FreeBSD, das ist ja auch Bildentschonend. Und ja, die SSDs haben ja auch so eine gewisse begrenzte Lebensdauer. Noch ein Tipp hätt ich, weil ich hab letztens auch an einem Server rumgespielt und das war eigentlich auch was Neues mit neuer CPU, der dann AES-NE hat. Wie heißt das? AES New Instruction oder so? Das ist diese Intel-Hardware-Unterstützung für AES-Encoding und Decoding oder irgendwie so? Ja, AES-NI nennt man das. Das ist so ein erweiteter Befehlssatz der CPU. Und dann habe ich Bios ein bisschen rumgespielt von dem Board und habe entdeckt, dass das bei diesem Board zumindest per Default ausgeschaltet ist und musste es erstmal einschalten. Ich habe das beinahe nicht gesehen. Da kann ich den Leuten auch nur raten, dass sie sich das nochmal genauer angucken, ob ihr Rechner dann auch wirklich halt... Na eigentlich dachte ich gar nicht, weil es ist Teil der CPU und es ist einfach da. Aber dieses Bios hat das anscheinend unterdrückt und ich muss das erst enablen. Du kannst das bei frivius.de beim Booten sehen. Da gibt es ja dann das Kommand D-Message. Und wenn du da guckst in den ersten 5-6 Zeilen, da ist ja deine CPU erwähnt. Und in der Zeile danach steht Features 1 und Features 2. Und bei Features 2 müsste da irgendwie am Ende AES-NI stehen als supportetes Feature. Wenn du drauf bist auf der Kiste, machst du einfach Het D-Message, dann müsste das da schon mit drin sein. Oder nicht Het D-Message, sondern ja... Ja doch, eigentlich schon.
Het D-Message?
Ja, den Kopf von D-Message anschauen. Also D-Message, Pipe Het, dann vielleicht so rum.
Was soll da stehen? Hier steht 3,6 GHz, K8-Class, CPU.
Ja, dann irgendwie da drunter irgendwie, zwei, drei Zeilen. Genau, hier Features 2. Und dann da ganz am Ende... Das ist Features 2? Ja, ich sehe da kein AES. Was ist das denn für eine CPU? CPU E3...
Xeon E3...
E3 1275, ja? Ich forsche da mal, vielleicht hast du ja auch gar keine. Ist das so eine Consumer-CPU? E3 1275?
Konsumer-Variante vom Xeon?
Ja, die haben inzwischen alle. Ja, du hast das auf jeden Fall. Wenn das dann in Features 2 nicht aufgelistet ist, dann ist das in deinem BIOS auch aus. Was ist das für ein Board?
Was weiß ich?
Hetzna, Tra-la-la, irgendwie... PX61 heißt das Produkt, glaube ich.
Verstehe. Na ja, du hast ja da einen Admin, habe ich gehört, der kann ja da nochmal forschen.
Genau.
Weil, ja, ich glaube, das OpenSSL schaltet da schon automatisch drauf um, wenn das supported ist. Und das bringt schon ein bisschen. Was hat deine Kiste weniger zu tun?
Ja, also ich hoffe, dass einiges beschleunigt wird dadurch. Und jetzt nochmal zu dem Thema Download-Server. Weil nachdem dann erstmal alles lief und sozusagen die alte Funktionalität wieder hergestellt war, und schneller und überhaupt und mit mehr Wumms und Bumms, kamen dann sozusagen erstmals auch wieder so Begehrlichkeiten auf mit naja, was will man denn jetzt eigentlich irgendwie machen? Und dann wurde erstmal so ein bisschen geguckt, was passiert denn auf dem Server eigentlich? Und dann fallen dann doch zum Beispiel so Freunde auf, da gibt es dann so Leute, die feuern einfach mit enormen mit enormer Nachfrage auf irgendwelchen Dateien rum. Irgendwelche durchgedrehte Transmission BitTorrent-Klines, die sich einfach im Staccato einen einzelnen Block ziehen. Immer denselben.
Das Problem heißt hier wieder Java, nämlich der sogenannte J-Downloader. Und dem sagst du halt hier folgendes Pfeil, und dann macht er erst mal acht oder weiß nicht, wie viele 16 Connections auf, also HTTP jetzt alles, und ballert da parallel los, weil halt viele Provider irgendwie einzelne Connections limiten. Und der nimmt einfach mehrere Connections und ballert halt parallel.
Ja, aber der macht das dann über Stunden und so.
Also Leute, die so ein Mirror ziehen und so?
Keine Ahnung, was die da machen, die laden einfach die ganze Zeit immer wieder denselben Block. Ich mein, die sollten das schon irgendwie jetzt mal haben.
Ah, defekte Clients meinste.
Ja, so war es.
Ja, ist ein großes Übel.
Defekte Clients, durchgedrehtes Skripte, also es ist jetzt noch nicht so richtig, so weit sind wir jetzt noch nicht, aber das ist sozusagen jetzt mal eine Erkenntnis, dass man da so ein, es gibt da irgendwie so Fail-to-Ban oder sowas, was man so dazwischenschalten kann, was dann eben solche Clients erkennt, also quasi jetzt auf HTTP, also auf Request-Ebene im Engines, oder Engine X. Gingsten, Gingsten.
Das ist halt ein Engine.
Im Ging's.
Motor X.
Im Ging's, ich sag jetzt Ging's. Also der Ging's, der kann sowas irgendwie integrieren, keine Ahnung, ich kenn mich da noch nicht so gut aus, wie auch immer, das Ziel ist, solchen Clients dann einfach dedizierte Fehlermeldungen zu präsentieren.
Oder einfach zu sagen, ok, jetzt ist es angekommen.
Es gibt ja da auch definierte Fehlermeldungen, die man machen kann, was weiß ich so, 429, Too Many Connections oder irgendwie sowas. Und wir haben auch schon ein paar andere lustige, eigene Fehlermeldungen ausgedacht, die man vielleicht auch nochmal machen könnte. Was weiß ich, 523, The Goddess Dislikes You. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, was will man eigentlich, was will man eigentlich loggen? Und das Merkwürdige ist, diese ganze Web-Server-Software, die hat zwar so Logging-Features, aber eigentlich sind diese ganzen Logging-Features immer nur für Systemadministratoren. Das fängt schon irgendwie an mit dieses immer alles so pro Woche und so weiter anzuzeigen, aber es gibt vom Haus aus überhaupt keinerlei Methodiken, um jetzt erstmal so an den eigentlichen URLs, die angefragt werden entlang, irgendwelche Statistiken zu akkumulieren, sodass man sich dann halt immer wieder so Skripte bauen muss und so. Und jetzt, was wir so jetzt mal angedacht haben, ist zum Beispiel, ich hätte gerne mal eine Statistik dafür, darüber, da sind wir im Prinzip auch schon, das kann man relativ leicht einschalten, indem man sich das einfach mitloggen lässt. Ich will halt jetzt mal rausfinden, wie schnell werden die Dateien eigentlich im Mittel geladen? Also das ist defaultmäßig ja nicht anders, man kann sich ja noch ins Logfile mit reinschreiben lassen, wie lange hat diese Verbindung jetzt eigentlich bestanden, sodass du eben ausrechnen kannst, hier so und so viele Bites wurden da gerade geladen, in dieser Zeit, in diesem Zeitraum. Und das akkumulierst du und machst halt dann dein Mittel und dann kannst du halt sagen, ah okay, die Mediendateien hier werden im Schnitt mit diesem Speed übertragen. Was schon mal eine ganz interessante Information ist. Weil das sagt dir halt etwas aus über deine Gesamt-Performance. Weil hilft mir nichts, auf irgendeinen komischen Chart zu gucken, wo ja, du hast eine Episode veröffentlicht und zehn Minuten lang hast du irgendwie ein Gigabit rausgehauen und danach wurde es etwas ruhiger. Ja, okay, gut, das hätte ich jetzt auch schon vorher sagen können, dass es so ist. So ist es halt immer bei Podcasts. Aber du weißt halt nicht, in dem Moment wo eben, und das ist ja zu 99 Prozent der Zeit einfach der Fall, eben nicht alles komplett ausgelastet ist, wie schnell kriegt denn sowohl die Maschine die Daten nach draußen bzw. wie schnell schaffen es diese Netzwerke ihren Kunden diese Daten auch zu vermitteln?
Aber ist das nicht egal, wenn das Gigabit voll ist, dann kann dir doch egal sein, ob das 200 User waren oder 100 User, weil sie saturieren deine Leitung und du schiebst halt Zeug raus.
Sie saturieren ja nur ein Bruchteil im Monat. Das ist ja nur ein kurzer Moment. Ich veröffentliche eine Freak Show und dann ist da halt mal 10 Minuten Terror. Und da ist die Leitung saturiert. Aber im Mittel, wie schnell kriegen denn die Leute denn jetzt das eigentlich geladen? Das ist für mich eine Größe, mit der ich arbeiten kann. Ist mein Server schnell, heißt ja nicht nur, ist die CPU schnell, oder was weiß ich, ist er unter Spitzenlast schnell, sondern ist er da, wo er steht, mit seiner Netzwerkanbindung in alle Richtungen, was für eine Downloadzeit wird eigentlich real ermittelt? Vor allem, wenn mir einer sagt, dein Server ist langsam, dann weiß ich ja überhaupt nicht, was die Vergleichsgröße ist. Ich kann nicht sagen, ja.
Na, die Vergleichsgröße ist wahrscheinlich das, was der User sonst hat, weil er sagt, er ist langsam. Aber ich meine, wie willst du denn von deiner Serverseite feststellen, ob langsam oder schnell ist, wenn du halt nicht den gesamten Weg bis zu deinem User kennst? Und den kennst du ja nicht.
Ja, den muss ich halt ein bisschen besser kennenlernen.
Ja, aber den kannst du nicht kennenlernen.
Warum?
Na, wie willst du das machen? Wenn ich bei dir klicke, ich weiß, ich hab hier 60 MBit. Wenn ich irgendwie klicke, maximal ist immer so 1,6 MBit. Wenn ich das bei dir jetzt irgendwie in File klicke, dann, wenn das mit 1,6 MBit kommt, bin ich happy, weil bei mir ist sozusagen, weiß ich, der Bottleneck ist bei mir und nicht mehr bei dir, weil mehr geht bei mir nicht. Wenn ich aber merke, okay, das tröpfelt hier mit 100 Kilobyte rein, dann könnte ich mich bei dir melden, könnte sagen, hier Tim, also 100 Kilobyte ist wirklich ein bisschen dünn. Aber du, von deiner Seite, wie willst du das feststellen?
Ja, ist eine gute Frage.
Nein, das geht, da nützt ja auch nichts. Also, findest du dann raus, ob die Leute V-DSL haben oder ein normales DSL, oder ob sie nur 6 MBit bezahlt haben und sie künstlich gedrosselt werden, also das kriegst du doch alles gar nicht hin.
Mit kriegst du nicht mit, hat ja viel damit zu tun, dass die Software einfach solche Informationen nicht generiert, obwohl sie unter Umständen theoretisch ja auch vorlegen. Zum Beispiel die TCP-Verbindung, die da gefahren wird. Wenn ich die schneller bedienen kann, als der User sie annehmen kann, dann geht ja die Windows-Size an einer bestimmten Stelle auch runter. Also eine TCP-Verbindung verhält sich ja anders wenn da beim User so ein Bottleneck ist, als wenn das nicht da ist. Sowas wird halt nicht gelockt, weil das müsste dann schon sich in dem Fall der NGINX irgendwie aus seinem TCP-Stack holen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich diese Information überhaupt so bekäme oder die Möglichkeit hätte, das überhaupt zu betrachten. Genau über sowas denke ich jetzt gerade nach. Was man auch machen kann ist, das ist so das nächste Experiment, was wir da gerne tun würden, dass man sich eben anschaut, welche IP-Adresse kommt da und dass man dann ein Lookup macht in irgendeiner Tabelle, was für ein Provider das ist. Also ich würde gerne mal zum Beispiel mal Mobilfunk von DSL und Telekom von U2 und Inland und Ausland, also all solche Sachen mal grundsätzlich erstmal voneinander trennen. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob man am IP-Range noch mehr, also du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht ansehen können, was das ist, weil wenn in der Straße einer DSL, eine andere hat eine VDSL, dann ist das wahrscheinlich immer noch derselbe Number Range, der da zum Einsatz kommt. Also das denke ich mal nicht, dass man dem jetzt im Einzelnen so viel ansehen kann. Aber du kannst zumindest schon mal grob zum Beispiel zwischen einem Mobilfunknetz und einem DSL-Netz, denke ich mal, gäbe es die Chance da unterscheiden zu können. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen ins Unwissen hinein, aber das fände ich mal eine interessante Statistik. Bloß dazu musst du eben dann entsprechende Software einsetzen, die auf deinen Log-Files arbeitet und das eben dann auch so rausliest. Also einfach mal einen Download-Server, der einem einfach mal auch was erzählt über die Realität, wie es denn dann ist mit der Beziehungswelt nach draußen. Damit ich einfach mal eine qualifizierte Antwort geben kann, wenn du ja immer sagst, ja langsam. Ja, was hast du da?
Was du noch bei den FreeBSD machen kannst, die unterstützen auch dieses ECN, wovon wir schon mal geredet haben, das sogenannte Explicit Congestion Notification. Und ich glaube, das ist per Default off bei FreeBSD und du könntest das mal einschalten auch für deine ausgehenden Sachen. Ich glaube, für Incoming wird es unterstützt, wenn deine Gegenseite das haben will, aber du benutzt es nicht aktiv, wenn du Connection aufmachst, wobei die ja alle sowieso zu dir kommen und du dich nicht zu denen hinconnectest, richtig? Die User connecten ja zu dir und du nicht zu denen. Das heißt, die kommen ja schon zu dir und wenn die dann ECN nutzen, dann machst du das auch schon. Also so gesehen musst du eigentlich doch nichts einschalten. Hat sich erledigt gerade. Ging schnell.
Ja, so viel zu meinem Server.
Ja, macht immer Spaß mit neuer Hardware, oder?
Genau, vor allem mit Admins zu arbeiten, die irgendwie auch was können. Ja, ich kann nicht mehr so. Also ich versteh das zwar alles, aber ich hab einfach, bin weit weg von Daily-Administration. Und wenn man da einfach, weiß ja wie es ist, wenn man da nicht einfach die ganze Zeit im Strahl steht, dann wirst du halt die ganze Zeit nach hinten geworfen, mit was du jetzt irgendwie, mit der FreeBSD-Version, jetzt mit der CPU, dann noch mal im BIOS und so weiter. So Details, wie du sie jetzt gerade abgeliefert hast, da gibt's ja dann noch sehr viel mehr. Hatt ich ja auch schon vorher diverse Probleme mit VMs. Ja, so und das Ziel ist so ein bisschen, da mal eine gute Konfiguration hinzubekommen. Und wenn das mal so richtig cool ist, dann kann man das auch mal dokumentieren und mal so ein bisschen rausgeben. Und ich würde mir vor allem mal wünschen, dass da eben mal ein bisschen intelligentere Auswertungstools sind. Entweder direkt so modular in dem Web-Server, der halt sozusagen während diese Verbindungen laufen auch mal mit lauscht. Das wäre ja auch mal ganz interessant. Ich weiß nicht, was NGINX dafür Möglichkeiten hat, dass man eben sozusagen per connection Dinge analysiert. Ja, stalled da was. Weil am Ende, jetzt hab ich im Log-Fall hab ich halt ein Endresultat. Ich sehe aber nicht, hingen die Verbindungen lange und dann gingen sie wieder ganz schnell. Oder war die durchgehend schnell? Das wär ja zum Beispiel schon mal eine ganz interessante Information.
Aber grundsätzlich schiebt deine Kiste jetzt mehr raus als vorher. Also hast du vorher zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, hast du vorher ein Gigabit und hast du jetzt ein Gigabit und warst vorher nicht komplett ausgelastet und jetzt schon, wenn du eine Sendung veröffentlicht, kannst du schon sowas irgendwie so grob sagen? Oder hast du vorher...
Ich hatte jetzt mit dieser Letty und VM das Problem, dass ich eigentlich ein Gigabit, da hab ich nie ausgelastet bekommen, aber es lag wahrscheinlich einfach an dem Letty und an dieser VM zusammen. Und jetzt hab ich problemlos das Saturiert bekommen.
Okay, und die vorher vielleicht deine Platten rödelten wie Sau, weil du nicht genug speichertest und jetzt hast du mehr Speicher und das auch alles bisschen ruhiger geworden.
Jetzt hab ich vor allem so dedizierte Festplatten, die direkt am System sind, versus vorher irgendwelche, weiß ich nicht, über Remote...
Na gut, aber das wahrscheinlich auch waren vorher fette Storage-Systemen, die schon leistungsmäßig was können.
Ja, aber ich weiß halt nicht, inwiefern die dazu eingetragen haben, weil ich das einfach nicht so gut analysiert habe. Dafür war das mir dann irgendwie jetzt auch nicht wert, das groß anzuschauen. Ich wollte halt einfach alles einmal neu aufsetzen und dann war ich jetzt dabei.
Also interessant wär ja, wenn so ein Pie kommt, ob das wirklich dann nur diese eine Podcast ist, der dann sowieso nach einer Minute oder noch schneller im Rahmen liegt und eigentlich seine Platten überhaupt gar nichts mehr zu tun haben mit Laden, sondern dass alles schon aus dem Rahmen rausgeliefert wird.
Ja, also die CPU hat sich immer schon gelangweilt. Das ist die Bottlenecks. Ich kann's hier nicht genau sagen, was das Problem war, aber es ist eine Mischung aus Software, Setup und irgendwie merkwürdigen Verhalten von dieser VM.
Ich find, wir könnten ruhig nochmal System-Admins loben. Macht man zu selten.
Habt ihr eigentlich auch mitbekommen, dass jetzt endlich klar ist, warum Mädchen nicht programmieren können?
Oh, da waren so viele Favoriten drin. Ich weiß gar nicht, was mein Favorit ist.
Weil es keine Rosatastaturen gibt?
Die gibt es ja wohl. Ich kann nicht kodieren, weil meine langen Eier es schwer machen, das Bild zu sehen. Außerdem ist es schwer, meine Augen zu öffnen, mit diesen oberen Stränden Mink, die sie immer runterweichen. Sonst bekommt man Toxik Schock Syndrome, das enthält, dass deine Arme amputiert werden. Das macht es auch noch schwerer, zu kodieren.
Hast du alles schon mal gehört, oder? Aber du kannst trotzdem nur mal lachen.
Ja, natürlich. Und ich wette, dass die Hälfte das nicht verstehen, dass es nicht ernst gemeint ist.
Das habe ich auch schon befürchtet.
Natürlich.
Kannst du das ein bisschen genauer fassen?
Es ist auf so vielen Ecken großartig.
Erzähl mal eine. Eine, die ich vielleicht nicht sehe. Keine Ahnung. Es ist ganz offensichtlich, machen sie sich einfach lustig über gängige Vorurteile und Dinge, die man als Frau an den Kopf geschmissen bekommt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer so unterschwellig formuliert wird, in Foren auftaucht oder einem permanent in Diskussionen aufgeworfen wird oder ob das jetzt einfach nur total übertrieben ist und sich mit eher was anderes repräsentiert.
Ich hab halt noch nie mit was Negatives erfahren. Also so kleine Fotzeleien, ja, steh ich aber halt drüber, weil ich einen großen Bruder hab und irgendwie manchmal bin ich das Gefühl. Also da gibt man dann halt mal irgendwie Kontra und dann merken halt auch einige ganz schnell so Ups, mit der kann ich wohl nicht alles machen.
Weil die hat einen großen Bruder.
Ja, ich bin halt auch bei einigen Sachen einfach auch arschig dann zurück. Also ich kann auch die Retour-Kutsche dann mal...
Ja, die Herren brauchen es ja auch hart. Schrippen heißt es. Diese Spirale muss auch irgendwie aufgelöst werden. Ich meine, es gibt ja gerade sowas, die diese ganze Programmierer-Heritage betrifft, auch so diverse Geschichten, die ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht... wo ich mich nicht so belesen habe. Aber es gab ja mal eine Zeit, da waren eigentlich fast alle Programmierer, Programmiererinnen.
Weil sie dachten, dass es keine Arbeit ist, wo man irgendwie nachdenken muss. Genau. Dann kam so dieser Hype auf mit, da muss man denken, das passiert nicht so von alleine. Algorithmen, das ist irgendwie doch nicht, was dir zufällt.
Ich kenne dann auch die Verschwörungstheorie, dass die Gewerkschaften da reingegangen sind und als Ideales Anstellungsprofil formuliert haben, wir brauchen jetzt auch Menschen, die sozial nicht so entwickelt sind, weil die könnten sich dann besser konzentrieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich auch noch mal so eine bösartige Verschwörungstheorie ist. Aber es ist unzweifelhaft, dass es dann sozusagen so eine Gegenbewegung gab und dann die Männer sich mehr oder weniger dieses Programmierfeld wieder angeeignet haben und dann auch in der Folge gut daran gearbeitet haben, quasi die Verhältnisse umzudrehen. Und da befinden wir uns dann halt teilweise immer noch. Was ehrlich gesagt das Kotzigste ist irgendwie an dieser ganzen Computerwelt, an der ich in den letzten 30 Jahren teil gehabt habe, dass das einfach so eine Scheiß-Männer-Veranstaltung ist.
Ich glaube, daran wirst du erst was ändern, wenn sich die Gesellschaft mal anfängt zu ändern und das eben schon im Kindesalter angefangen wird mit irgendwelchen Barbie-Rotze und alles ist pink und Ballett und all diesem Mädchenscheiß. Entschuldigung. Ich finde, es ist halt kein Wunder, wenn du dich nur dafür interessierst, weil du nur das Vorgesetz bekommst. Also ich finde super, dass ich einen großen Bruder habe. Da wirst du schön auf seine Bahn gebracht, was er so toll findet. Und das ist dann halt so, guck mal, ich habe da so einen Rechner. Und dann musst du dich halt mit beschäftigen, weil er weiß schon ganz gut zu verhindern, wie er dir andere Sachen nicht mehr so sparkhaft macht. Und ich meine, dann beschäftigst du dich halt erstmal, ah, zwangsläufig damit, findest du es am Anfang vielleicht gar nicht so geil, aber dann kriegst du es halt irgendwann doch selber mit. So hm, das ist irgendwie doch cool und... Ich weiß nicht, du entwickelst dich ja dann schon so ein bisschen anders, wenn dir andere Sachen gezeigt werden. Also Lego war bei uns zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding, was halt immer da war. Ich weiß nicht, das ist halt schon irgendwie eine andere Art, womit man sich halt beschäftigt und ja.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ein gutes Beispiel ist mit dem großen Bruder, das kann ja nun auch gerade...
Nee, aber das kann ja auch ein anderer Einfluss sein.
Das kann ja aber auch genau so eine Anti-Haltung nach sich ziehen.
Natürlich, natürlich, aber ich mein, hätt ich das nicht gehabt, diesen Input? Warum ich zum Beispiel in Peru so gerne Meerschweinchen gegessen war, weil ich hab das so als Trauma gehabt aus meiner Kindheit.
Was hast du gemacht?
Ich hab Meerschweinchen gegessen in Peru.
Meerschweinchen gegessen in Peru?
Ja, in Peru ist das ein Nationalgericht. Ist da ein Nationalgericht. Ist äußerst lecker, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Echt?
Es sind nicht die Hausmeerschweinchen, die wir hier haben.
Und zwar deutlich größer.
Na ja, so viel ist an den Dingern nicht dran. Ich kann dir da mal ein Foto zeigen.
Also eher so wie Nagerwachteln oder so? Naja, Wachteln sind doch diese mini kleinen Vögel, an denen nichts dran ist. Und sie werden trotzdem gegessen.
Warte mal, so von einem Größenverhältnis? Also eher so ein Rabe?
Eher so ein Rabe?
Also wenn du es vergleichst mit der Stadttaube, da war es so klein, ist es eher so ein Rabe, das ist schon ein bisschen größer. Nee, aber das war auch so ein Kindheitstrauma, weil irgendwie alle Mädchen haben irgendwie so ein Meerschweinchen gehabt. Und wenn du die halt gefragt hast, wollen wir was machen? Ja, wir spielen mit unserem Meerschweinchen. Da war ich so raus. Naja, weil ich das halt nicht kannte. Also irgendwie hab ich dann eben halt nicht offensichtlich mit Meerschweinchen gespielt.
Aber sind Meerschweinchen nicht nachtaktiv?
Ja, das sind sie.
Die pennen doch tagsüber sowieso. Und wenn man sie nicht pennen lässt, dann werden die irgendwie auch ein bisschen dröppelig.
Das weiß ich halt nicht. Ich kenn sie wie gesagt gut auf dem Teller, aber nicht.
Ich hatte nur Hamster als Kind.
Ich hatte eine Schildkräuter.
Hamster waren sehr nachtaktiv. Weil ich gewusst hätte, dass man die auch essen kann.
Also ich hatte überhaupt kein Haustier und hab's auch nicht vermisst irgendwie.
Das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich meine nur so, also wenn du halt so irgendwie mit Sachen aufwächst, dann ist das halt für dich total natürlich, damit umzugehen. Und so ein Computer und so war für mich irgendwie schon immer relativ natürlich. Und ich hab das nie in Frage gestellt, dass ich das dann nicht für mich irgendwie als Ding claimen kann.
Aber du beobachtest doch dann auch so dein Frauenumfeld.
Ich hab in der Tat, zwei meiner besten Freundinnen sind, einer ist Informatikerin auch. Hallo Schatz. Und die andere ist Mathematikerin. Ja, das stimmt. Und die andere ist aber Logopilin. Ist nicht Nerd. Stimmt nicht, die ist auch Nerd. Aber ja, das sind so... Ich hab schon auch einige Nerd-Mädchen...
Nee, das mein ich aber jetzt nicht. Sondern eher so, wo eigentlich bei denen so das...
Wo es Klick gemacht hat?
Nee, wo es nicht Klick gemacht hat. Also was sie sozusagen davon abgehalten hat. Weil ich mein, das ist ja so ein bisschen das, was dieses Video jetzt auch insinuiert, dass man eben hier gegen Vorbehalte, Vorurteile, Abwehrhaltung, Mauern stößt, die unüberwindbar zu sein scheinen oder so absurd sind, dass man einfach gar keinen Bock hat, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Einige sagen halt so dieses typische, versteh ich halt eh nicht, aber ich weiß nicht, wo das herkommt. Das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Einige haben das halt irgendwann gesehen. Zu Schule war für einige wahrscheinlich auch der Ausstabgegenepunkt, wenn man eine gute Schule hatte, die so was wie Informatikunterricht hatte, dass es irgendwie doch spannend ist und dass man halt auch nicht Eingeräte bekommt. Und diese Erfahrung hatte ich halt auch überhaupt nicht. Und nee, hatte ich nicht. Also mir hat nie jemand gesagt, so Informatik, das machen eh nur Jungs. Und Programmieren, das wirst du nie können. Nee, das ist so nicht richtig. Ich hab für Hearts of Code mal einen Workshop gehalten über Visualisierung. Ja, aber nicht aktiv, im Sinne von ich gehöre da zu den Packers.
Okay, du organisierst das jetzt nicht so mit, aber du hast das mal mitbekommen.
Genau, ich hab mal einen Vortrag da gehalten. Oder einen Workshop sogar über Visualisierung mit D3. Und das war recht cool, also es hat Spaß gemacht. Waren alle auch super interessiert. Also es war auch eine breite Mischung von Informatik-Studentinnen bis ich bin schon voll im Job drin und programmiere.
Also sollten wir noch mal kurz sagen, was Hearts of Code ist.
Ja genau, Hearts of Code ist so ein Berliner Hacker-Space. Ich weiß nicht, ob man Hacker-Space sagen kann, weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie einen Space jetzt haben.
Sie haben noch keinen, aber das ist wohl das Ziel.
Genau, wo ausschließlich alles für Frauen ist. Ich will jetzt aber nichts falsch sagen. Die sagen so Frauensternchen und ich müsste jetzt gucken, was die Definition von Frauensternchen ist.
Aber sagen wir mal, primär auf Frauen gerichtet ist, ganz unabhängig davon, wie dann die konkreten Polizisten aussehen, die ich jetzt noch nicht gebe, weil es auch keinen Ort hat.
Also sie wollen damit vor allen Dingen so einen Safe Space schaffen, dass es eben Frauen trauen, auch zu solchen Workshops zu gehen, weil sie es vielleicht sonst nicht trauen würden oder sich denken, naja, weiß ja nicht, ob ich da dazu passe. Diese Barriere wollen sie halt eigentlich runterbrechen.
Und mehrern dann jetzt sozusagen durch andere Hacker-Spaces, die es nun gibt, ne?
Ich hab die letzte Entwicklung nicht so richtig mitbekommen. Ich glaube, sie haben jetzt mit einem Hacker-Space zusammen...
Einen Präsehain, diesen X-Hain.
Genau, eine Abmachung, dass sie, glaube ich, Donnerstags den Space bekommen können. Und vorher, also der Workshop, den ich gehalten habe, war in der Singerstraße bei der Open Knowledge Foundation in einem Büros. Genau, und das war dann so ein kleiner, kuscheliger Workshop mit, wir waren, glaube ich, sieben, acht Leute. Und über, ich glaube, sechs Stunden, also es war ganz schön anstrengend, dann einen Workshop über sechs Stunden zu halten, genau. Und es war wirklich ein breites Spektrum, eben wie gesagt, Entwicklerinnen noch im Studium, Leute, die auch mehr vielleicht aus der Design-Richtung, glaube ich, waren, glaube ich, auch dabei, die eigentlich gar nicht programmiert hatten vorher. Ich will jetzt aber nichts Falsches sagen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie sehr es gemischt war.
Wie Huckel.
Der kam ja auch so als Designer in den Club gelatscht.
Kam als Programmierer raus. Es war eine schöne Atmosphäre. Spaß gemacht. Ich hab jetzt auch gesehen, wir gehen ja auch regelmäßig zu einem netzpolitischen Abend. Ich glaube auch, ein Club zum Dienstag, wir gehen zusammen als Gruppe zu einer Veranstaltung.
Im Prinzip ist es so ein bisschen, wir bauen uns unser eigenes Netzwerk auch. Das finde ich eigentlich auch super. Was bei den Herren häufig nicht gesehen wird, es gibt ja dann immer so diese etwas lächerlichen Debatten, aber teilweise kann ich es auch nachvollziehen, wie es sich entwickelt, auch wenn ich es anders sehe. Ist man dann eben das gleich so als ja, wieso, wozu soll denn das gut sein, oder wozu soll denn das nötig sein? Wir haben das ja auch so nicht. Bei uns kann ja dann auch immer jeder kommen, weißt du, so die Argumentation. Und die geht halt so ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung, weil man einfach, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht schickt, dass einfach das männliche Netzwerk, das ist halt einfach Default. Das ist halt immer da. Das muss gar nicht ausgerufen werden, das existiert einfach. Und dass man einfach da an den Geschlechtskanten, dass sich da einfach auch bestimmte Umgangsformen ändern und dass es einfach ein anderes Verständnis des Miteinanders manchmal gibt, wo man auch einfach mal von dem anderen einfach mal eine Pause braucht, das leuchtet einfach nicht jedem ein. Es gab auch gerade um diese Safe Spaces oder um diese geschützten Räume und so weiter auch auf dem CCC-Kongress über die Jahre auch immer wieder so Fights. Weil das dann gewünscht wurde und dann gab es dann irgendwie gleich so eine Gegenbewegung. Ich muss auch sagen, ich war auch selber da auch Teil, also ich meine mich so daran erinnern zu können, dass ich da jetzt nicht so granatenhart dagegen agitiert habe, aber ich habe so ein bisschen die Bedenken geteilt, warum denn das nun erforderlich sein soll. Ich habe einfach diesen Umkehrschluss nicht im Kopf, nicht fertig bekommen. Ich habe es einfach nicht zu Ende gedacht oder nicht zu Ende gefühlt bekommen. Ich habe einfach die Rahmenbedingungen nicht verstanden. Und das hat glaube ich auch sehr viel damit zu tun, dass man sich überhaupt nicht klar macht, manchmal wie aggressiv oder unangenehm der Umgang in so Nerd-Szenen manchmal einfach ist. Weil das für einen selbst so normal ist und weil man damit umgeht und weil man ja selber nie benachteiligt ist und nicht sozusagen Opfer ist, sondern immer in dieser privilegierten Rolle, dass man das überhaupt nicht schnallt, wie störend das manchmal sein kann. Diese Besserwisserischen...
Das gilt aber für alle.
Das ist halt auch so ein Punkt. Ich denke nämlich auch, dass das, für mich spielt dieses Geschlecht halt nie eine Rolle. Das sehen halt einige anders, weil sie scheinbar in Geschlechter denken müssen, keine Ahnung. Aber ich denke halt auch, dass das eine Sache ist, die sowohl bei Männern da ist als auch bei Frauen. Und das auszunehmen, dass es keine Frauen gibt, die so sind, ist Quatsch.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, dass die Frauen die dazwischen quatschen, sondern dass es auch nicht Junghack, aber junge Jungs gibt, die halt auch ein Problem damit haben, wenn da halt so einer dazwischen quatscht und so Oberlehrer mäßig ist.
Das spielt sich auf verschiedenen Ebenen ab. Man kann genauso gut auch mal für so einen U19-Tag planen und da quasi so einen geschützten Raum machen, weil halt einfach keine Besserwisserischen mit Zwanziger, die so vorkommen wie die Geilsten.
Die will man weglassen, die nerven.
Einfach mal weglassen, und zwar nicht um das immer zu trennen, sondern um überhaupt erstmal da, Schutzraum klingt auch mal so ein bisschen, als gäbe es gleich so eine Bedrohung. Das ist gar nicht das, was ich meine. Das ist nur einfach so ein, ich würde es eher mal so als Ruheraum bezeichnen, wo man einfach mal so eine Ruhe hat und in Ruhe mit gleich Altrigen, gleich Geschlechtlingen oder was auch immer in der jeweiligen Gruppe, um die es geht, das einigende Ding ist. Dass man da einfach mal die anderen mal weglässt, um einfach mal so zu kommunizieren, wie man es untereinander braucht. Schönes Beispiel sind ja auch hier die Autistengruppen, die auf dem Kongress aufgeschlagen sind vor ein paar Jahren, haben wir ja hier auch schon öfter darüber gesprochen, die auch ihre eigenen Kommunikationsbedürfnisse haben. Und so wird man auch wahrscheinlich in der Zukunft noch sehr viel mehr Gruppen ausmangern. Aber es ist natürlich ganz offensichtlich, dass wir einfach jetzt überhaupt bei diesem generellen Mann-Frau-Ding, bei allen Überschneidungsformen, die es geben mag, dass da einfach am meisten zu leisten ist. Vor allem, wo einfach auch am meisten zu gewinnen ist, finde ich. Also wo man einfach so viel dazugewinnen könnte. Und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass so die Zeit gekommen ist. Also ich verspüre, dass seit ein, zwei Jahren merke ich, die Dinge ändern sich. Vielleicht ist es nur, weil die Dinge sich bei mir ändern, aber ich habe auch so in meinem Umfeld so den Eindruck, dass das ist jetzt einfach, da hat jetzt einfach eine kritische Masse von Männern auch begriffen, dass es sozusagen hier auch in sich nicht um einen Kampf handelt, sondern dass man sozusagen hier einfach was zu gewinnen hat. Genau, ein Miteinander und dass da einfach weitere Zutaten in die Suppe kommen, die man einfach gerne mal dabei haben muss. Und dass es jetzt sozusagen auch erforderlich ist, da mal konkrete Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Dass man nicht immer nur so Larifari daherreden kann, und das wäre ja auch schön und theoretisch. Und was habt ihr denn überhaupt? Ist doch alles gar kein Problem mit, ich bin doch ganz nett zu euch. Sondern eben einfach auch mutige Schritte macht. Wie zum Beispiel so, ah, okay, ihr meint, ihr bräuchtet jetzt mal so einen Ruhrbereich. Ihr habt den und dann diskutieren wir da auch nicht drüber. Und dann ist das auch kein Thema. Anstatt dass man das dann die ganze Zeit thematisiert und ob denn das nötig ist. Und so dieses, vertraut ihr mich nicht? Oder denkt ihr, ich wär böse? Das sind ja auch immer so komische Argumentationen, die da noch mit reinkommen. Und das ist natürlich alles Unfug. Ja, ja, also ich, auch alle, die hier zuhören, können da auch mal Schritte unternehmen.
Ja, man sollte das endlich auch mit diesen Geschlechtern halt so abschaffen und dieses, also ich find das so generell so furchtbar, also als ob immer dieses Geschlecht so eine, also diese krasse Rolle spielen würde. Also ich mein, so what?
Genau das jetzt tun, damit das einfach nicht mehr ne Rolle spielt, weil derzeit spielt es halt leider noch ne Rolle, aber niemand will das halt eigentlich.
Naja, ich fand diese Diskussion in Amerika mit Target und den Klos irgendwie so krass, wo habt ihr mitgekriegt, irgendwie in Amerika große Einzelhandelskette glaube ich ist das, Target heißen die. Die haben einfach gesagt, ja unsere Klos klar, jeder kann die Klos benutzen, die er für seine Gender-Rolle für richtig empfindet und gut ist und dann brachte ein dermaßen Widerstand von so fundamentalistischen Christengruppen los, das war einfach unglaublich.
Ja, mit dem North Carolina-Gesetz und so.
Ja, genau und Boykott-Target und so weiter.
Ja, das ist auch lustig, wir hatten das ja auf dem letzten Kongress auch mit diesen Unisex-Toiletten, wo das ja auch mal ausgerufen wurde.
Ja, wir haben das ja aus praktischen Gründen gemacht, früher auch. Ja, weil halt 90 Prozent Typen da waren und nur ein paar Mädchen, also 10 Prozent, und die Klos waren immer leer. Ja, und dann dachten wir, scheiß drauf, wir machen das jetzt einfach hier so und das stört auch gar keinen und so was. Und jetzt sind natürlich mehr Frauen, hat sich so ein bisschen geschiftet und jetzt machen die das aber auch absichtlich wohl immer weiter so, dass das halt einfach für beide Seiten nutzbar ist.
Genau, wobei es ja nicht alle sind, es gibt durchaus noch ein paar, die sozusagen auch wirklich explizit so...
Was ich auch gut finde, man muss ja Leute nicht absichtlich vor den Kopf stoßen, wenn das Leuten nicht passt, dann sollen sie halt weiter anstehen auch zur Not.
Sehr spannend war, dass eine Unisex-Toilette mit dem Pissoirse-Unisex war. Da war ich in der Tat kurz irritiert. Also ich meine, mich stört das halt auch nicht und renne halt rein und denke mir so, oh Pissoirse, stand da jetzt wirklich Unisex dran und das war halt so dieses äh, ist eigentlich auch egal.
Ich geh einfach mal. Genau.
Ja, aber das ist dann auch... Nee, aber was ich erstaunlich fand, ich war ja... Ich war am Sonntag in der Philharmonie bei dem Mitsing-Chor von dem Rundfunk-Chor unter Leitung Simon Halsey, blablabla. Und da war halt in der Pause, wenn da so 1000 Choristen irgendwie gleichzeitig aufs Klo müssen, dann ist halt selbst die Infrastruktur einer Philharmonie halt so ein bisschen überfordert. Und da war das dann irgendwie plötzlich ganz normal, dass halt auch Frauen irgendwie ins Männerklo sind. Und dann aber auch so, ich sag mal, so zehn Meter an Pessoise vorbei, weil erst ganz hinten waren die Kabinen. Also es war so... Also dein Eindruck, dass sich da was bewegt, den kann ich so nachverziehen irgendwie. Wenn selbst in dem Bereich, wo halt das Durchschnittsalter bei mindestens 50 ist, halt sowas auch geht irgendwie.
Vielleicht sollten die zukünftigen Toilettenbauer, Designer, Architekten das halt so machen, dass die Pessoise eben nicht vorne sind und dann kommen die Toiletten, sondern halt dann doch wieder andersrum.
Oder etwas größere, etwas breitere, tiefere Trennwände.
Ja genau, besser getrennt.
Genau, und dann war es, warum ich das jetzt überhaupt angesprochen habe, dann gab es, und ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Regelung war auf der Republika, ihr wart glaube ich alle nicht da, ne? Also ich hab keine Ahnung, ob da irgendwas verkündet wurde, ich hab jetzt auch nicht nochmal nachgeschlagen, vielleicht weiß jemand im Chat Bescheid, ob es da irgendwie eine Regelung gab, aber sie hatten die Beschriftung der Klos so gemacht, dass sie eigentlich, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie es aussah, aber im Kern war immer nur grafisch notiert, ob hier sozusagen ein Urinal im Angebot war oder nicht. Also da stand halt nicht Mann, Frau, X, Y oder sonst irgendwie so was in der Richtung, sondern die Klos waren einfach nur mit markiert hier mit Urinal und hier nur mit Sitzen. Ja, so Kabinen, Sitz, so. Und ich bin dann in irgendeinem Klo dann halt reingerannt, auch schon so voll im Kongressmodus, wo halt Klosymbol dran war. Urinal brauchte dann halt auch nicht unbedingt. Ich wäre also damit voll zufrieden gewesen. Wurde aber dann von einer älteren Putzkraft einer Dame irgendwie abgewimmelt, dass ich doch hier nicht reinzugeben habe. Weil das ja wohl offensichtlich nicht für mich sei. Ich mir auch nur dachte, du bist ja irgendwie total rückständig. Und was interessiert dich denn das jetzt überhaupt? Ich hab dann jetzt keinen Aufstand deswegen gemacht, bin dann irgendwie ins andere Klo reingegangen, weil ich dachte mir, das macht jetzt auch nicht aus. Und ich wusste ja nicht genau, wie die Regelung jetzt war, ob ich jetzt sozusagen nur die Symbole falsch interpretiert habe, oder ob sie die Symbole falsch interpretiert hat. Aber am Ende hatte ich den Eindruck, das war eigentlich auch so gemeint. Und dann dachte ich mir auch so, warum eigentlich auch nicht? So ein Quatsch, was soll diese bekloppte Trennung? Da müssen wir irgendwie die Hirne weiter öffnen.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass die das auch gar nicht gemerkt hat, dass das so gemeint war. Also die gehörte wahrscheinlich zum Haus.
Die hatte keine Kenntnis von dieser Regelung.
Sonst standen da wahrscheinlich immer Frauen dran an dem Klo. Und für die war das auch einfach nicht klar gewesen, dass diese Trennung jetzt mal aufgehoben ist.
Das waren die vom Kongress, die Bilder.
Wie war eigentlich die Regelung auf der Klo-Party? Was war das eigentlich für ein Klo? War das ein Unisex-Klo?
Ja, das war ein Unisex-Klo. Und zwar eins mit Urinalen.
Genau, Unisex-Klo mit Urinalen.
Daran können wir nicht mehr erinnern.
Doch, doch, hinten, ganz in der Ecke. Das haben ja alle nur in diesem kleinen Vorderraum getanzt.
In den letzten Kongressen war ich sehr oft an die immer in dem Klo, weil es irgendwie von dem Sendezentrum das nächste war, was vor der Unisex-Regelung halt ein Herrenklo war. Ja, und deswegen war das irgendwie, ja.
Na gut, ich glaube, wir haben unsere Tipps hier abgelassen. Wer Lust hat, sich da anzuschließen an dem Projekt, auf Twitter, Hearts of Code in einem Wort, ist das Projekt und wir finden das gut.
Genau, und die Mädels freuen sich auch bestimmt, wenn ihr schöne Vorträge habt und Workshops halten wollt. Wissen verbreiten ist immer gut.
Ja, genau.
Ich glaube, da geht es auch von Hardware über Software bis alles. Die wollen ziemlich viel machen. Also die haben keine Einschränkung.
So, wollen wir zum nächsten Thema übergehen?
Findest du nicht, dass der Towel Day schon wenigstens eine Erwähnung nach zwei Stunden verdient?
Ja, deswegen schiebe ich hier auch gerade unsere Themen ein wenig hin und her. Möchtest du dich äußern zum Towel Day?
Habt ihr alle überhaupt ein Handtuch dabei? Also ich hab meines Vorbildes nicht mitgebracht.
Ernsthaft?
Was denkst du denn, was das ist?
Du wohnst ja auch um die Ecke.
Das ist ein Handtuch?
Das ist kein, ja genau.
Das sieht mehr so aus wie, weiß ich nicht.
Nein, das ist ein modernes Traveler Micro-Fleece-Handtuch.
Ja, das sieht so aus wie so ein Tuch zum Abwischen von einem 60 Zoll Bildschirm.
Ja, ist es aber nicht.
Das kann man auch als Reisehandtuch benutzen.
Als ich den Kollegen zum ersten Mal eine Handtuch dachte, oh ja scheiße, schon wieder eins von diesen Plastik-Gängen, dass irgendwie mehr wasserabweisend ist als aufsaugend, aber dann musste ich tatsächlich feststellen, die funktionieren verdammt gut. Also es saugt wirklich was weg. Es gibt ja wirklich so komische Plastik-Handtücher, da bleibt das Wasser gar nicht dranhaft, die saugen gar nicht auf.
Es gibt doch von denen zwei verschiedene. Ich hab die Variante, die glatt ist, und es gibt eine, die so pusherlich ist. Die pusherliche, finde ich, A ist hier nicht für Klettererhände gemacht, und B finde ich auch nicht, dass sie so Wasser richtig gut aufsaugt. Also das ist echt ein Unterkauf.
Naja, und dann gibt es natürlich noch Weichspüler. Wenn man seine Handtücher mit Weichspüler bearbeitet, dann kann man sich hinterher auch nicht mehr abtrocknen.
Richtig?
Nee, weil die dann auch kein Wasser mehr aufnehmen. Vor allen Dingen hast du das Gefühl, du hast dich abgetrocknet, und möchtest eigentlich gleich unter die Dusche, weil du dieses Zeug auf der Haut hast. Also ich verstehe das nicht, warum Leute das tun.
Aber bitte.
Auf jeden Fall, Letty weiß, wo ihr Handtuch ist.
Hängt.
Und das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal lüblich zu erwähnen, weil heute ist ja Towel Day. Ich muss sagen, ich habe so ein etwas gespaltenes Verhältnis zu diesem Towel Day, weil der halt vom Datum her eigentlich gar nichts bedeutet. Der ist halt mal einfach mal so ausgerufen worden, weil er irgendwie noch mit nichts anderem belegt war offenbar.
Das ist nicht irgendwie Todestag von Clemens Adams oder so?
also das würde mich jetzt sehr überraschen. Ich bin bisher immer davon ausgegangen, dass es keinen Bezug gibt, aber ich kann jetzt noch mal sicherstellen, also der 25. Mai steht jetzt nicht im Geburts- oder in Todes-Kontext. Gestorben ist er zwar im Mai, aber im 11. Mai 2001 übrigens. Das ist also jetzt 15 Jahre her. Oh man, ey, da kann ich mich so erinnern. Ich hab leider kurz vorher, dummerweise, weil ich im Urlaub war, im Jahr 2000 war er nämlich in Berlin. Und diverse, warst du da eigentlich auch, Dennis? Warst du da irgendwie schon dabei? Da waren irgendwie so einige von uns. Und ich hab ihn aber mal live gesehen, einmal.
Ich hab nur Terry Pratchett live gesehen, einmal.
Okay, aber wir bleiben jetzt bei Douglas Adams.
Ich betreib keinen Personenkult.
Dem schließe ich mich an.
Ja, na Personenkult muss man ja bei ihm überhaupt nicht betreiben. Der ist ja so schon cool.
Aber zu Ozzy Osbourne gehen wollte, letztes Mal bevor.
Hallo, sterben kann alle wie die fliegen. Da muss man ja mal Privilegien setzen.
David Bowie und alle.
Ja, ich möchte wenigstens Black Sabbath einmal live gesehen haben. Ich habe gehört, dass die Waldbühne eine super gute Akustik haben soll. Deswegen hinter dem Olympiastart. Nee, das haben schon ziemlich viele gesagt.
Naja, es ist halt Open Air. Also ich meine, Open Air eine schlechte Akustik hinzukriegen, das ist fast unmöglich.
Es gibt einige Tontechniker, die auch das hinbekommen.
Aber ja, ich hab da mal Die Pesch Mode gesehen und es war recht witzig, weil Die Pesch Mode aufgetreten ist, wie sich der gemeine Die Pesch Mode Fan das nicht vorstellt. Also man kennt ja vier Typen hinter Keyboards. Und Lichter bewegen sich, aber sonst nichts. Und dann traten die da auf, hatten einen Flügel, einen echten analogen Flügel auf der Bühne, ein Schlagzeug. Und dann kam ein unglaubliches Unwetter. Die gesamte Bühne war ungefähr fünf Zentimeter mit Regen nass. Der Sänger, der rannte über die Bühne, hatte irgendwann die Schuhe so nass, dass er sie einfach abgeworfen hat. Und dann sind vor ihm und hinter ihm immer so ein Trupp von drei Leuten mit so Wasserschiebern über die Bühne, um die Bühne wieder hinzukriegen. Es war sehr schön. Also ich fand das super.
Und lass mich raten, er hat knarnlos seine Show durchgezogen und Spaß gehabt?
Auf jeden Fall.
Das finde ich an Deepest Mode sehr wert.
Auf jeden Fall. Das hat die überhaupt nicht gestört, ganz im Gegenteil. Die ist so nach der Art, endlich mal ein Konzert was anderes ist.
Das sind auch die einzigen, die schon so lange auf der Bühne sind, wo ich abnehme, dass sie immer noch Spaß an dem haben, was sie machen. Bei mir aus sind sie halt hundertmal auf Drogen, das ist okay, aber wir haben echt Spaß.
Mein Lieblings-Live-Album ist dieses Die Pech Mode 101, oder wie das heißt, diese Konzerte in USA, in einem der größten Stadien, die es so gibt. Pasadena oder sowas.
Ich hab's probiert.
Dieses schwarz-weiß Cover, ist egal. Jedenfalls kann ich nur empfehlen, das ist wirklich gut.
Und was auch sehr lustig war an diesem Konzert, war, die Pashmode hatte eine Weile nichts von sich hören lassen. Und dann kamen sie plötzlich mit diesem einen Album raus, wo der Sänger lange Haare hatte und einen Bart.
Personal Jesus-Zeit.
Und halt auch nicht mehr gebleichte Haare, sondern braune, lange Haare und mehr als unrasiert. Zu dem Zeitpunkt bin ich auch immer so rumgelaufen. Und ich sah halt aus wie dieser Sänger. Und da waren diese ganzen blondierten Kurzhaarigen und haben mich alle irgendwie neidisch angeguckt. Entschuldigung.
Also ich zitiere kurz die Wikipedia. Bei der Auswahl des Termines für den Towel Day spielte kein besonderes historisches Datum eine Rolle. Vielmehr war er ein Kompromiss aus dem Wunsch, möglichst bald nach dem Tod Douglas Adams diesen Gedenktag zu begehen und der Notwendigkeit genügend Vorlaufzeit zu haben, um die Nachrichten in die Welt zu bekommen. Der 25. Mai hat sich seitdem als Gedenktag etabliert, wird hier behauptet. Andere Termine, die eine Bedeutung im Bezug zu Douglas Adams haben, sind der 11. Februar, der 42. Tag des Jahres, sein Geburtstag, 11. März, und sein Todestag, 11.
Mai.
Diese wurden für 2002 als neue Termine des Towel Day diskutiert, aber nicht akzeptiert. Leima, Leima. Wie kann man so einen wichtigen Gedenktag auch noch, wo es so um Zahlen, also meine Fresse, 11. Februar wäre Golden gewesen. Ja, wäre ich sofort mit dabei, kann man sich auch gut merken. Oder halt auch sein Todestag, auch in Ordnung, obwohl das vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen, weiß nicht, morbid ist oder so. Also 11. Februar als Towel Day wäre ich voll dabei gewesen. 25. Mai ist so, naja, sie waren halt zu faul. Also erst waren sie zu hektisch, weil ich meine, man muss ja nicht zwei Wochen danach sofort ein Towel Day machen. Warum? Ich meine, lasst sie nur erstmal ordentlich ableben. Ja, der ist ja noch nicht mal...
Lass ihn doch erstmal unter die Erde bringen.
Der ist ja noch nicht mal ordentlich zersetzt.
Der ist ja noch nicht mal kalt.
Ja, der ist noch nicht mal kalt und dann wollt ihr irgendwie schon mit euren Haltdurchhören rumlaufen. Also das ist meiner Meinung nach ein Fail. Wie auch immer. Es ist insofern okay, als dass... Ich finde, dass Douglas Adams sehr wohl verdient hat, so eine Würdigung, meinetwegen auch einmal im Jahr, zu erhalten, weil wer von euch, die Zuhörer, vielleicht noch nicht geschneit hat, soll es ja geben. Also ich bin ja nun jemand, der nicht gerade dafür bekannt ist, besonders viel gelesen zu haben. Also ich bin sehr schlecht in Büchern, weiß wenig und kenne fast nichts. Bei Douglas Adams kenne ich fast alles und bin da irgendwie komplett in den Topf gefallen, deswegen mag das bei mir auch noch mal so ein bisschen übersteigert sein. Trotz alledem, der Typ war einfach ein Checker vor dem Herrn und er hat irgendwie diese moderne Welt so früh, schon so gut gesehen und das merkt man halt auch in diesem ganzen Humor in dem wichtigsten Buch, was er geschrieben hat oder in den wichtigsten Büchern, nämlich der Serie Paar Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Und was sollt ihr denn den Fehler gemacht haben, diesen Film gesehen zu haben?
Welchen?
Ja, das ist mal verfilmt worden, den zweiten, also der Hollywood-Film später, vor ein paar Jahren.
Den fand ich aber ehrlich gesagt ziemlich geil.
Ich hab den ausgeblendet bei mir, der spielt bei mir keine Rolle.
Also der...
Ich fand den an zu vielen Stellen einfach zu falsch. Der hat bei mir einfach nicht resoniert.
Also warum? Er hat das Drehbuch dafür geschrieben.
Wie er hat das Drehbuch dafür geschrieben?
Er hat das Drehbuch geschrieben.
Für diesen Film, das Drehbuch. Dass das genauso gespielt wird, das bewahre ich stark zu bezweifeln.
Also dass die Handlung so ist, ja, doch.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst. Und da stand auch drin, dass Marvin anders aussehen soll, als in seinem Buch beschrieben?
Naja, das stand da wahrscheinlich nicht drin, keine Ahnung.
Und er soll sich auch anders verhalten und so. Also ich weiß nicht, egal, mag man eine andere Meinung haben. Ich finde, man sollte diese Bücher lesen, weil dieser Wortwitz ist einfach sein Markenzeichen. Und der wird meiner Meinung nach in diesem Film verloren.
Ich finde ja, das allerbeste von ihm ist ja immer noch der zweite Dirk Gently Roman, wo es am Anfang um dieses Sofa geht, was nicht aus dem Treppenhaus rauszukriegen ist. Und ohne jetzt zu spoilern.
Was war das denn? Der lange 5 Uhr Tee der Seele? Genau, der erste war der elektrische Mönch.
Ja, ja, der ist auch schon geil. Aber der zweite ist so geil, weil du denkst dir so, da passiert am Anfang komische Dinge und du denkst dir, naja, da hat er halt irgendein Kram geschrieben. Und auf der letzten Seite fallen alle Puzzle-Pieces so ineinander und du denkst dir so, what the fuck? Wie hat der Mensch das geschafft, dieses Buch so aufzubauen, dass plötzlich aus dem Nirgendwo alles Sinn ergibt?
Hätten sie sich bei Lost mal ein Stück abgucken können?
Das fand ich sehr geil. Oder war es doch der Elektrische Mönch? Ich weiß es nicht. Einer von den beiden.
Ich bin jetzt auch gerade ein bisschen... Die habe ich, glaube ich, nur einmal gelesen und da steige ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen aus. Ich erinnere mich nur noch an diese Beschreibung von diesem elektrischen Mönch am Beginn des Buches von Der Elektrische Mönch.
Ja, großartig!
Ich sehe wie Der Elektrische Mönch ist eine......
ist eine Maschine, die für einen glaubt. Weil wir haben Videorecorder, die für einen Fernseh gucken.
Genau.
Und wir haben Anrufbeantworter, die für einen telefonieren. Und jetzt gibt's den elektrischen Mönch, der für einen glaubt. Damit man nicht selber glauben muss.
Ja, das ist...
Lobend erwähnen will ich auch noch mal an dieser Stelle ein anderes Buch, was vielleicht manche gar nicht kennen. Dieses kleine Buch. The Meaning of Life.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das gelesen hab.
Das ist so geil. Das kann man auch gar nicht lesen. Das ist nämlich ein Wörterbuch. The Meaning of Life. Also zunächst einmal handelt es sich über ein Nachschlagewerk. Und das Buch ist so ein relativ kleines, kompaktes Ding. The Meaning of Life. Also L-D-F-F. Nicht The Meaning of Life, sondern The Meaning of Live. Von Douglas Adams zusammen mit John Lloyd. Außerdem ist noch so ein roter Aufkleber drauf, wo drauf steht, this book will change your life. Und dann kannst du da halt so Dinge nachschlagen. Und in diesem Buch, und im Übrigen gibt es auch eine hervorragende deutsche Übersetzung davon, wo ich wirklich im Staub kniehe von den Leuten, die das gemacht haben, weil ich das einfach für unübersetzbar gehalten habe, als ich das erst mal in der Hand hatte. Aber tatsächlich ist die deutsche Version auch ausgesprochen komisch. Aber man will sich natürlich erst mal dem Original zuwenden. Und The Meaning of Life ist eine Beschreibung von Dingen, die jeder kennt, für die es aber keinen Namen gibt.
Jaja, ich erinnere mich.
Und die Wörter, die denen zugeordnet sind, sind Ortsnamen aus Großbritannien. Das heißt, sie haben sozusagen irgendwelche Käfer genommen, die kaum einer kennt. So, haben diese Wörter einfach als Verben oder Substantive behandelt und sie dann Dingen zugewiesen. Was ich nie vergessen werde, ist zum Beispiel das Verb to throb. T-H-R-U-P-P. To throb ist der Vorgang, wenn man ein Lineal nimmt und es zur Hälfte auf ein Tischende legt und dann die eine Seite anschlägt, which makes the other end go... So lautet dann die Beschreibung. Oder, da weiß ich jetzt leider nicht mehr genau, was das Wort war, was ich dafür gewählt habe, aber halt auch unsere Ortschaft, ein Wort, was eine Menge von Autos beschreibt, die alle auf der Autobahn in derselben Geschwindigkeit fahren, weil eins von ihnen ein Polizeiauto ist. Fantastisch, und so geht das da nur die ganze Zeit, und du blätterst da rum und denkst so lustig, lustig, lustig, und dann denkst du irgendwann mal, hmmm, da gibt es noch ein Wort, was ich vielleicht nachschlagen sollte. Weißt du welches? Weil das Buch heißt ja The Meaning of Liv, und dann schlägst du halt nach und Liv, es steht natürlich drin, es ist halt auch wieder irgendein Kaff. A book, whose contents are totally beliedt by its cover, especially when it has a sticker on it, which says, this book will change your life. So meta, so großartig. Also, ja, ich bin Douglas Adams Fan und werde es immer bleiben. Und es ist sehr, sehr, sehr schade, dass dieser Mensch so früh vor uns gegangen ist, der, ich meine, der ist 2001 gestorben, und ich weiß noch, 99 oder so muss das gewesen sein, das war noch bevor er in Berlin war, das war 2009, 98, in der Zeit hat er gefordert, warum denn, also er hat sein Unverständnis darüber geäußert, Forderung, warum denn bitte nicht alle Hotels eine Ethernet-Steckdose haben. Das hat er 98, 99 in die Welt gebracht und wir alle so, genau, und der Rest der Welt so, wovon redet dieser Mensch? Ich meine, ich bitte dich, Ende der 90er-Jahre, niemand hatte doch auch nur am Ansatz auch nur eine Schäckung, wovon er geredet hat. Und er hatte so Recht, und sollte noch mal 10, 20 Jahre dauern. Und das sind einfach die Leute, die meiner Meinung nach die richtigen Leute sind für Science-Fiction. Und auch wenn man den Anhalter liest, der Anhalter ist einfach voll mit wunderbaren Vergleichen. Also du kriegst ja die ganze Zeit das Weltall erzählt, aber eigentlich ist es halt unsere bekloppte Gesellschaft.
Aber weißt du, was er nicht dazu gesagt hat, zu der Ethernet-Steckdose? Es muss doch ordentliches Internet rauskommen.
Ja, na gut, die Ethernet-Steckdose ist halt dann auch gekommen. Und selbst das Reddison in Hamburg hat es letztes Jahr geschafft, endlich mal diese blöde PIN-Code-Eingabe abzuschaffen, weil sinnlos. Das wird langsam besser. Langsam besser.
Ja.
Soviel zu Douglas Adams. Ich hab auch noch eine Ankündigung zu machen, bevor ich es wieder vergesse. Und zwar, hab ich das hier eigentlich erzählt, dass wir neulich diese Veranstaltung hatten? Die Subscribe, was ja mal unsere PodLav-Konferenz war.
Stimmt, da war was.
Genau, das heißt ja jetzt Subscribe. Und das ist sozusagen die zweieinhalb Tage Vollversion dieser Veranstaltung, die zweimal im Jahr stattfindet. Direkters Cut. Und wir werden dann die nächste Subscribe haben in München vom 14. bis zum 16.10. Und das wird dann sozusagen etwas größer. Und das heißt es ist so vollwertige, was heißt vollwertige, aber es hat, sagen wir mal, so Konferenzformat und mit einer entsprechenden inhaltlichen Planung und lalala. Also so eine kleine Konferenz, keine aber fein, mit Workshop-Komponente. Und jüngst gab es dann aber eben auch die Bestrebung doch mal, abgesehen davon, dass wir uns jetzt halt nach München zwischen expandieren und mal probieren, von da aus mal eine neue Community zu erreichen. Auch noch mal in ganz andere Regionen vorzustoßen, die noch nie einen Podcast anzuvoll gesehen hat. Und ja, das wird jetzt auch passieren, aber in leicht anderer Form. Und zwar wird es so eine Art Podcast-Workshop-Tag geben in Wien. Also aller Österreicher aufgepasst. Am 4. Juni, das ist bald, ja, Samstag, nächste Woche, gibt es dann einen Tag im Sektor 5, quasi die Ankonferenz-Variante unserer Subscriber und deswegen nennen wir sie Unsubscribe. Und findet da von morgens bis abends statt. Und da kann man sich auch irgendwie anmelden, das Sendezentrum Unsubscribe und dann ist man dabei. Kost nichts und alle sind glücklich. Und ja, sollten Podcasts aus Österreich dabei sein, ich würde euch gerne dort alle sehen. Wir suchen auch noch Leute, die Beiträge liefern und die dann andere, also entweder Formate vorstellen oder andere interessante Inhalte dazu beitragen, damit wir da ein lustiges Tagesprogramm haben und am Abend geht das dann mit dem Bierglas in die Hand.
Haben die denn Stühle, auf denen man mehr als eine halbe Stunde sitzen kann, ohne dass einem der Arsch weh tut?
Wieso würdest du das bezweifeln wollen, dass das so ist?
Naja, bei der Subscribe selber waren diese Stühle ja doch, also ich hab da gelitten.
Achso. Na, ich glaub die Stühle in München sind auf jeden Fall schon mal besser und anders und für wen kann ich keine Aussage treffen und... Na, München, sitzen kann man da.
Im Zweifelsfall, es gibt auch Reise, wie heißt das, im Kopfkissen.
Du, ich bin in München sehr lange in der Schule gesessen, also so ist es nicht.
Ernsthaft? Na, weißt du aber, wie das ist.
Zeig mal deine Liste, Herr Hirr.
Ich hab noch mehr Themen, aber ihr dürft jetzt auch mal was aussuchen.
Ja hier, ich hab hier ein neues Spielzeug mir geholt. Ist jetzt schon ganz schön lange her, ich hatte das auch schon mal dabei. Der Huckel hatte die auch schon mal auf, meinte, uiuiui, ordentlich Bass, aber ich glaube in der Sendung, haben wir es nicht mehr erwähnt, falls doch, kommt jetzt noch mal der gleiche Content und wenn es nicht der gleiche Content ist, weil ich jetzt plötzlich was anderes erzähle als beim letzten Mal, dann... sind die da, weil ich mich nicht mehr erinnern kann, genau.
Hab ich die schon mal gesehen?
Gesehen hast du sie schon mal, ich hatte sie schon mal auspackt. Also das geht hier, wir machen jetzt wieder mal Product Placement hier. Wie heißen die Dinger? Zenheiser sind das und zwar Noise Cancellation Kopfhörer und die heißen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie die heißen, wie heißen die? Momentum glaube ich, die heißen die, weil es steht hier nämlich gar nichts drauf und ich hab jetzt, du kannst sie ja mal austesten. Ich hab auch, damit wir gar keinen Bluetooth machen müssen, also die sind kabellos per Bluetooth, aber ein Feature ist zum Beispiel, sie haben hier so einen ganz kleinen Mini-Stecker, dann kannst du sie zu einem normalen Kabel-Kopfhörer machen.
Mikroklinke, Nano-Klinke?
Ja hier 2,5 mm auf 3,5 und die 2,5 mm kann man reinstecken und verdrehen, so dass sie auch drinbleiben. Dann kannst du das jetzt hier in deinem iPhone stecken. Ja, der Roddy müsste dann jetzt deine Kopfhörer dann auch mal abnehmen, das ist halt natürlich doppelt geht das nicht. Ja und ich glaube, wenn du sie jetzt nicht einschaltest, dann hörst du jetzt ganz normal, dass es halt Kopfhörer sind. Wenn du sie aber einschaltest, dann müsste das ein neues Cancellation dazu kommen.
Du musst schon deinen Mikrofons ein bisschen näher halten, wenn du siehst.
Hör ich denn was, wenn...
Ja, also jetzt sozusagen sind sie wirklich analog über das Kabel. Jetzt kommt sozusagen Energie des Soundes, den du hörst von deinem iPhone. Und das heißt, auch wenn die Batterien zum Beispiel mal leer sind, würde man damit jetzt ganz normal die Kopfhörer benutzen können, was schon auch ein Feature ist. Kommt nix, das ist aber jetzt schon... Na, da ist irgendwo so ein Knopf und den musst du lange drücken.
Ich finde die gar nicht hier. Bist du sicher, dass die von Sennheiser sind?
Ja, hier, du musst hier drücken und eine Weile festhalten. So, jetzt haben wir sie ausgemacht, so. Ja, ich bin ganz sicher, dass die von Sennheiser sind, weil das Sennheiser-Logo ist drauf. Also, die heißen Sennheiser Momentum Wireless, irgendwie so. Und kommt jetzt auch was? Na, der Rolli hört uns jetzt natürlich nicht mehr, weil er ist ja im Neues kennenzulernen.
Dich hört keiner, du musst dein Mikrofon, nein, nicht von unten besprechen, von der anderen Seite. Dreh es einfach, drehe einfach.
Ja, ich höre dich schon noch, aber Neues gecancelt. Jetzt muss ich mal den Schalter suchen.
Funktioniert, also das Ding quatscht halt.
Sennheiser Momentum, der neuen Momentum-Kopfhörer. Inspiriert von Menschen mit Momentum.
Momentum ist doch Impuls.
Haben wir Momentum?
Momentan schon.
Wenn Momentum vom Moment kommt, vom ja, whatever. Ist egal, also die haben den normalen Bluetooth-Modus.
Vielleicht haben wir die ja auch inspiriert. Kann ja sein, wenn die sind mit dem Momentum.
Weiß ich nicht. Also die haben, kannst du die mit Bluetooth connecten, mit zwei Geräten, zum Beispiel mit deinem iPhone.
Was ist denn das hier für eine Werbung?
Und deinem Laptop.
Erlebe einen Sound-Panzer.
So kann ich nichts erzählen.
Du siehst immer, wie es uns immer geht, Dennis.
Nee, dir geht das, du wirst es so. Aber bei dir machen wir das nach fünf Minuten Kalender. Also man kann es perren mit Bluetooth, mit seinem iPhone und mit seinem Laptop. Und dann kommt aber schon das Problem, ich hab ja noch zu Hause einen Desktop. Und wenn man es mit dem dann auch noch perren will, dann will das nicht mehr, weil es ist ja schon mit zwei anderen Geräten gepaart. Und dann muss man erst eins irgendwie rausnehmen, dann muss man ein bisschen formeln. Also mit zwei Geräten ist super. Dann kann man easyen und her schalten.
Kann das Teil nur mit zwei Geräten perren?
Nee, du kannst das auch mit mehreren perren. Aber nur die letzten zwei sind sozusagen aktiv und du musst da nichts machen, um umzuschalten. Das ist wie mit dem Bose-Ding, was wir hatten. Du kannst dich erinnern. Und wenn man das dritte halt hat, dann muss man halt neu perren. Also da muss halt einer raus von den alten. Und der ist dann auch wieder raus. Also mit drei ist das blöd, mit zweien funktioniert es total super. Also zwischen Telefon und Laptop hin und her zu schalten, das ist gar kein Ding. Das geht alles schick. Und was noch cool ist, man kann ein USB-Kabel, damit lädt man es nicht nur auf, sondern wenn ich das halt damit auflade und dann in meinen Rechner stecke, dann ist es auch halt...
Ein USB-Audio-Device.
Genau, und dann kannst du da per USB sozusagen hören und auch, das hat ja auch ein Mikro drin, kannst das auch als Headset benutzen und kannst telefonieren zum Beispiel. Die Qualität des Mikros ist aber nicht allzu doll, da hatte ich mir ein bisschen mehr versprochen, aber es ist auch eher selten, dass man das macht, finde ich. Und wie gesagt, wenn zum Beispiel die Batterien leer sind, die so um die bis 20 Stunden halten, dann kann man auch hier so ein Analogkabel nehmen, zweieinhalb auf dreieinhalb Klenke und dann braucht man auch gar keine Energie und dann hat man aber auch kein Noise-Cancellation, natürlich wenn man den Kopfhörer auslässt und dann hat man auch nicht diesen doch etwas stärkeren Bass, der soll dann wohl auch weg sein, habe ich jetzt aber selber noch gar nicht getestet, weil das Analog nutze ich eigentlich nie, weil ich mag es ja eigentlich gerne kabellos.
Also da ist es natürlich ein Vorteil gegenüber von den Bose-Dingern, wenn da die Batterie alle ist, dann ist auch nichts. Oder wenn man sie ausgeschaltet hat, dann kommt gar nichts.
Ja, aber dann auch wieder, also man kann es ja schon vergleichen, ihr Pro und Contra, das was ich beim Hucke gesehen habe, weil der hatte das ja dann da dabei, bei diesem Bose kannst du dafür aber auch den Deckel öffnen, nimmst diese AAA-Batterie raus und kannst schnell mal eine neue rein machen, wenn du eine dabei hast, das geht bei dem wiederum nicht, weil das hier so Apple Style-in eingebaute Lithium-Ions sind, wo man halt auch nicht rankommt und wenn die auch mal durch sind, dann steht in der Doku hier, Manual von Zen, heißt das da nur Fachpersonal, dass die Batterien wechseln soll und aber ich denke mal, dazu sind die Geräte noch zu neu, dass das schon mal passiert ist. Das wäre dann jetzt eher zur Zeit ein Garantiefall, aber es soll wohl auch irgendwie gehen. Und was noch bei dem Bose zum Beispiel geht, da kann man ja das mit dem Noise Cancellation, kann man ja ein- und ausschalten, ne?
Ne, du schaltest nur das Ding ein und aus. Also entweder du schaltest es ein, dann hast du Noise Cancellation und dann hörst du auch Musik oder du schaltest es aus und dann hast du weder Noise Cancellation noch Musik.
Echt, man kann das nicht abschalten und Musik hören? Nee. Ach so, echt hab ich anders…
Zumindest bei diesem QC15 oder was das heißt, was ich da hab.
Okay, weil ich hab gelesen, dass es da beim Bose wohl gehen würde, weil bei diesem geht das halt auch nicht. Du kannst das Noise Cancellation wirklich nur weglassen, wenn das Ding ausbleibt und du das Analogkabel benutzt. Solange du das Ding einschaltest, ist auch immer dieses Noise Cancellation an. Und vom Noise Cancellation, der kann ich jetzt nicht so richtig vergleichen mit anderen Bose-Kopfhörern, weil ich die nie lange genug gehabt hab, als dass ich mir da ein Bild hätte machen können. Also wenn es ganz, ganz sehr leise ist, wie bei mir zu Hause mal, wo man sonst nix hört, dann hörst du von diesen Noise Cancellation so ein bisschen so ein Rauschen und wenn du sie dann abnimmst, hast du das Gefühl, dass es leiser geworden ist als mit Noise Cancellation. Aber dazu muss es bei mir zu Hause wirklich, wirklich sehr leise sein. Also wenn du irgendwie draußen auf der Straße bist und so weiter, dann hörst du auch dieses Rauschen nicht und dann ist es auch wirklich Noise Cancellation in Action. Wenn es sehr leise ist, dann klappt das nicht so.
Interessant. Also wenn er sozusagen nichts hört, dann fällt er darin, das Rauschen zu filmen und erzeugt da richtig Rauschen.
Eigentlich müsste er, wenn er wirklich nichts hört, müsste er sagen, alles klar, da ist ja gar nichts, ich mach mich mal aus oder irgendwie so. Das kriegt er wohl irgendwie nicht mit, weil wahrscheinlich die Mikrofone, die das messen, diese Stille sozusagen, das Eigengrauschen und sie filtern, sie arbeiten gegen sich selbst. Da müssten sie vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen dran arbeiten, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so schlimm, weil ja.
Also meine Erfahrung ist ja, dass die Dinge so richtig gut sind, die halt irgendwie so im Flugzeug, wo du so ein ganz unangenehmes, tiefes Brummen hast die ganze Zeit, die Triebwerke, alles vibriert, alles brummt.
Ja, das kriegen sie auch besser weg als die hohen Sachen.
Genau und du kannst, du kannst dir halt, das hab ich auch schon mal versucht, diese ganz normalen Baumarkt-Kapsel-Gehörschutz-Dinger, diese roten Mickey-Mäuse aufsetzen, das funktioniert einigermaßen.
Aber mein Kumpel hat so eine Dinger und das war schon ganz schön krass, die setzt da auf und das ist ganz schön viel weg.
Jaja, aber die neuesten Dinger, die machen halt untenrum wirklich den Bass komplett weg, komplett.
Habe ich noch nie probiert.
Also hast du dann oben noch so ein bisschen Rauschen drin, was du halt so hörst, aber ansonsten ist halt wirklich herrliche Stille.
Aber schlafen die sich gut? Also schläft es sich dann trotzdem gut mit den Dingern?
Nee, du hast natürlich diesen Klotz am Ohr und wenn du so wie ich gerne mal auf der Seite liegst, dann liegst du halt auf dem Kopfhörer. Ich kenne keinen Kopfhörer, auf dem man gut auf der Seite liegen kann.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein Problem, das stimmt schon.
Wenn dich das nicht stört und du nicht auf der Seite liegen willst, ist natürlich super. Beziehungsweise du hast natürlich, wenn du dann auf der Seite liegst und dann hast du natürlich über den Sitz und andere Teile wieder Vibration auf dem gesamten Kopfhörer, den er dann nicht noise gecancelt kriegt, also so Körperschall, der sich überträgt über Plastikteile und so weiter. Aber es ist einfach ein Unterschied, besonders bei längeren Flügen, wenn du das Ding auf hast, du musst ja auch nichts hören oder so, sondern es ist einfach mal 20, 30 dB, ich weiß nicht wie viel es sind, leiser und es ist einfach ein viel angenehmerer Geräuschpegel und du bist adrenalinmäßig nicht immer so am Anschlag, weil es so laut ist irgendwie.
Das ist eigentlich jetzt noch an, was dann nämlich auch kann ist, du kannst jetzt dreimal klicken und dann sagt er, wie voll er noch ist, ich hoffe es geht jetzt noch nicht, dass er wieder mein Telefon irgendwelche Leute anrufen will, weil das macht er nämlich auch. Nee, kommt nix mehr, hast ihn ausgemacht.
Hauptsache du rufst mich nicht an.
Wieso? Du bist ja da und kannst es dann. Du machst gerade laut, leise.
Wo kommst du denn jetzt eigentlich? Dennis schnuppert jetzt an seinem Kopf.
Nee, ich dachte, das würde man hören, aber irgendwie hört man das nicht. Man kann hier dreimal auf den Controller-Button drücken, mit dem man auch laut, leise und Next Track und so macht. Und dann sagt sie, wie viele Restminuten man noch hat und ob man nun laden muss oder nicht und so.
Ja, also ich hab jetzt mal wieder einen Apple In-Ear Kopfhörer für den öffentlichen Nahverkehr durch und ich bin jetzt am überlegen, was jetzt das nächste ist. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf das Zeug irgendwie, muss jetzt mal ein guter Kopfhörer her.
Aber In-Ear ist natürlich schon cool, weil man nicht so einen riesen Monster mit sich rumschleppt.
Und es dämpft auch relativ gut. Aber so gerade im Sommer willst du natürlich nicht so einen Klopper aufhaben.
Genau.
Ich kann die von Skullcandy ziemlich empfehlen. Die habe ich gerade und die Kopfhörer sind so leicht gebogen. Die sind so ein bisschen gebogen. Ich habe die mal beim ersten Podcast hier vergessen und habe fast geweint, weil ich dachte, ich hätte sie verloren. Die sind sehr gut gebogen und ich finde, die passen sich sehr schön dem Ohr an.
Und du hast sie nicht gekauft, weil die so ein schickes Design haben?
Gibt es sie auch anders als in grün-lila?
Ja, hier gibt es ganz viele Farben.
Blau zum Beispiel.
In schwarz gibt es sie auch.
Na gut, für 25 Euro kann man jetzt auch nicht so viel falsch machen, selbst wenn sie nicht so toll sind.
Ich finde sie dafür echt gut. Ich hatte mir danach die von Sennheiser geholt, die bei Amazon irgendwie total die tollen Bewertungen hatten. Und die fand ich so grottenschlecht im Vergleich. Und halt von der Passform nicht so gut. Also diese Passform ist, also ich finde sie ist total angenehm.
Haben die irgendetwas mit dabei, wo man das Ding aufwickelt und wegpackt?
Ich wickel sie immer an meinem Telefon auf, deswegen, nein, haben sie leider, oder was?
Also ich finde dieses Ding von Apple eigentlich auch ganz praktisch, wo man das halt immer wieder reinwickelt.
Achso, das sind jetzt diese In-Ears, verstehe?
Das sind diese In-Ears, ja.
Wir nutzen wirklich dieses Gerät, weißt du nicht, wie man Kopfhörer wickelt.
Aber ich wickel das auch, das finde ich schon ganz gut.
Wann ist denn das dreieckig?
Das sind jetzt die In-Ears, nicht die anderen.
Das sind die In-Ears, nicht die EarPods.
Was kosten die eigentlich?
Ich glaube, die kosten 79.
Die EarPods sind super praktisch eigentlich.
Ja, im Prinzip schon, aber bei mir halten sie nicht im Ohr. Ich hab die ungefähr 15 Sekunden im Ohr, dann fallen sie raus.
Ich kann das nicht erklären, aber ich hatte jetzt zwei Modelle, die mir irgendwann aus dem Ohr rausfielen. Dann hab ich mir neue gekauft, und die fielen nicht mehr aus dem Ohr raus. Ich kann das nicht erklären, aber so genau so war es. Ich weiß nicht, was sich bei denen verändert hat, aber...
Keine Ahnung, ich kann ja mal die probieren, die beim letzten iPhone dabei waren. Die sind auch unausgepackt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die anders gebaut sind oder ob die irgendwie in irgendeiner Form degradieren.
Aber die haben so einen richtigen In-Ear-Pömpel. Den drückst du dann rein und dann bleibt es halt einigermaßen lang.
Also, rausgefallen sind die mir auch noch nie. Ich hab sie auch beim Skaten, glaube ich, letztes an.
Aber jetzt wollen wir gerade dabei sind, weil wir sind ja ein Technik-Podcast. Ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Da gab es doch diese In-Ear-Vlootoo-Teile, die gar kein Kabel haben, sondern irgendwie das eine spricht mit dem anderen per irgendwie komisch Funk. Also eine Seite spielt den Bluetooth-Master und spricht mit dem anderen über was Proprietäres und du hast gar kein Kabel, sondern steckst nur noch zwei so eine Dinge ins Ohr. Gab es nicht irgendwie so ein... Gab es nicht irgendwie so ein Kickstarter-Project, wo die irgendwie so eine In-Ear-Vlootoo-Kopfhörer machen ohne Kabel?
In der Kategorie gab es schon alles als Kickstarter-Projekt.
Da würde mich interessieren, was da draus geworden ist.
Und wie lange hast du dann zwei davon?
Weil einer rausfällt und der dann weg ist? Ich glaube, du kannst wahrscheinlich, wenn du willst, sie trotzdem irgendwie verbinden. Ich bräuchte mich was für zum Motorradfahren, weil wenn du da noch so ein Schnürchen hast, dann irgendwas zieht vom Helm um und zieht hier sozusagen eigentlich, also schon beim Helm aufsetzen, zieht es ja am Kabel und zieht es dann wieder aus den Ohren raus. Das ist immer irgendwie blöd. Das heißt, wenn man die nur so reinsteckt, das wär's eigentlich. Wisst aber nicht, wie die heißen. Und hier, was sagt der Chat dazu? Der muss doch irgendwie eine Ahnung haben.
Was sagt der Schleck?
Aber die sind wahrscheinlich wieder noch Minuten hinterher und hören das erst, wenn wir schon drei Themen weiter sind.
Ja, die sehen so ein bisschen nach Hörgerät aus.
Ja, muss ja auch so sein. Und vielleicht in manchen Situationen willst du ja gar nicht zwei benutzen, sondern vielleicht sogar wirklich nur einen reinstecken.
Ja, das mag ja sein. Du möchtest nur trotzdem nicht, dass du irgendwann nur noch einen hast.
Join the whitelist.
Ja, gerne auch.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das die waren.
Gibt es sowas nicht sogar schon auf Amazon? Ich dachte, ich hätte sowas letztens gesehen.
Dash von Bragi meinen die da. Ich glaube, das hört sich eher so an wie das, was ich meine.
Bragi, Reisekissen.
Genau.
Das kann man mit laufen, Fahrrad fahren, schwimmen und enjoyen.
Schwimmen. Also die sind quasi wasserdicht?
Behaupten sie.
Wie 4GB Deutsch, 1000 Songs.
Das ist ein kompletter MP3 Player sozusagen. Das ist jetzt kein Headphone, sondern das ist so ein... Oder? Wireless Smart Earphone. Was meinen sie damit? One Touch Standalone Music Player. Ich glaube, da war das andere schon eher das, was du suchtest.
Eigentlich meinte ich die hier. Aber gut, wenn da noch mehr von den Produkten gibt. Naja, muss ich mir mal genauer angucken. Bezahlt.
Den Witz wollte ich auch gerade machen.
Nee, das hat nichts mit kaufen zu tun, sondern mit klauen. Daten.
Pass auf.
Ich fang mal ein bisschen vorne an. Also, es gibt ja so eine Eigenschaft an Hackern, die dir wahrscheinlich gar nicht weiter auffällt, bis ich sie gleich erwähne, die ich persönlich, also was für mich erstmal einer der Dinge ist, woran ich Hacker, also, Anführungsstriche, richtige Hacker erkenne. Also, es gibt natürlich viele Dinge, woran man sie erkennen kann, aber das ist so definitiv etwas, woran ich sofort merke, so, okay, things are right with you. Und zwar ist das das Verhalten in dem Moment, wo jemand an seinem Computer ein Passwort eingibt. Was macht der Hacker? Genau. Der Hacker guckt weg. Warum machen wir das?
Damit der andere sich nicht vertippt.
Man macht das halt, weil das einfach ein guter Stil ist, weil man einem Kodex folgt und man guckt halt nicht anderer Leute Passwörter ab. Das macht man halt einfach nicht. Ich glaube, das ist bei uns auch so eingebrannt, dass wir da halt einfach gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenken.
Man guckt auch nicht PINs beim Editkarten-Terminal aus.
Alter, also so jegliche Form von Passwort. Man macht es nicht und man versucht auch, möglichst deutlich zu machen, dass man es nicht macht. Also nicht übertrieben im Sinne von ich gucke sogar weg, so cool bin ich, sondern es ist Teil der Kommunikation. Es ist so, ja, ich habe gemerkt, du willst jetzt ein Passwort eingeben, du kannst das jetzt auch machen, weil ich bin jetzt im...
Das nennt man Respekt.
Genau, ich bin im Respekt Mode. Und das ist so was, das finde ich wirklich geil. Also das finde ich total cool. Das ist irgendwie so eine Eigenschaft, die hat man oder man hat sie nicht und das ist einfach mal so im Club und so weiter. Das ist einfach so dermaßen Standard, dass ich glaube ich bis heute noch, ich glaube ich habe mich noch nie mal mit jemandem darüber unterhalten, dass das so ist. Weil das einfach nur so ist. Das ist gut. Ja, warum ist das so? Weil wir sozusagen schon so ein bisschen Hacker-Ethik am Start haben und da gehört natürlich auch noch so das eine oder andere zu und was macht man halt auch nicht? Man klaut halt auch keine Daten, wenn man die Gelegenheit dazu hätte. USB-Sticks, die man mal so eben in die Hand gedrückt bekommt, Festplatten, auf die man was drauf spielt oder so. Man nutzt einfach diesen Moment nicht, um an irgendetwas zu kommen, woran man sonst auch nicht so ohne Weiteres rangekommen wäre.
Macht man halt einfach nicht, oder?
Macht man nicht. Und insbesondere tut man es dann nicht, wenn so arme Würstchen ankommen mit äh, mein Computer, nichts funktioniert mehr, alles kaputt, äh, lalala. Und dann muss man sich halt mal dieses Rechners annehmen und man verfügt sozusagen über einen bestimmten Zeitraum über alles. Man hat die Festplatte, man baut sie vielleicht sogar aus, man schraubt sie in andere Gehäuse rein, man macht alle möglichen Dinge und die betroffene Person steht mit Ehrfurcht daneben, weiß schon überhaupt nicht, äh, was Sache ist. Früher war das immer so diese besonders schönen Auswüchse, weil was hat man gemacht, wenn so Probleme mit der Festplatte waren? Dennis?
Früher?
Was hat man dann so gemacht, wenn man so ein Laptop oder so eine Festplatte in die Hand gedrückt bekommt, mit der irgendwas nicht stimmt?
Kopie, komplette Kopie, oder?
Bevor man irgendwelche Maßnahmen ergreift, was ist das Erste, was man macht?
Davor noch?
Ohr ranhalten.
Ohr ranhalten, exactly.
Das war jetzt ganz gut, auch wenn man noch ein bisschen raten musste, aber eigentlich war es, glaube ich, ganz gut. Geraten jetzt.
Das war sehr gut geraten. Das war genau das, worauf ich hinaus wollte. Und diese Ehrfurcht, mit der mich die Leute angeschaut haben, wenn ich irgendwie so mein Ohr auf diese Festplatte gehalten habe, um so 30 Sekunden einfach mal so zu hören, was das Dateisystem eigentlich tut. Schrammt der da immer auf demselben Blog rum oder wiederholt sich da irgendwas? Ich meine, das hat einem wirklich eine ganze Menge Informationen darüber gegeben, was da jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade nicht in Ordnung war. Ob das ein Hardware-Problem war, ein Software-Problem war. Irgendwie konnte man daraus was irgendwie machen. Aber dieser Blick von den Unwissenden, wenn man so ein Ohr an die Festplatte dran hält und daraus irgendwelche Schlüsse zieht, dann bist du irgendwie sofort in so einem Gott-Modus. Naja, nicht ganz so unrecht. Aber trotzdem, für uns ist das halt normal. Aber wir wissen vor allem irgendwie umzugehen mit den Daten. Wir kopieren sie dann. Und was auch immer wir vielleicht auf temporäre eigene Datenspeicher kopiert haben, um einen Auslagerungsbereich zu haben, haben wir dann wieder gelöscht und das interessiert uns nicht weiter. Und als wäre es nie geschehen. So sind wir. Nun hatte ich auch einmal den Fall, dass jemand ankam und genau solche Laptop-Probleme hatte. Und das war, glaube ich, irgendwann Ende der, oder was? Das muss so 97 gewesen sein. Ja, irgendwie so war es 97. Ein Freund rief mich an und meinte, ja, ein Bekannter von ihm hat ein Problem mit einem Laptop, Mac. Damals gab es ja nicht so viele Leute, die sich irgendwie damit auskannten. Und dann landete irgendwie das System halt bei mir, aber nicht nur das System, auch der Besitzer dieses Laptops kam mit und das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich keine besonders nennenswerte interessante Geschichte gewesen, hätte es sich dabei nicht um Joseph Weizenbaum gehandelt. Immerhin einer der Urväter der Informatik, Schöpfer von Elisa, Teil dieser ganzen frühen KI-Geschichte und so weiter, also so eine kleine Ikone und irgendwie auch ein sehr netter Mensch, der dann schon so ganz huzlig irgendwie bei mir ankam und halt über Laptop-Probleme klagte. Und im Rahmen dieser Maßnahme, da war halt irgendwie Macintosh, HFS, Mac OS, was weiß ich, 9, 8, was das damals war, war halt einfach das ganze Fallsystem zerranzt und musste einfach mal komplett wegkopiert und wieder draufkopiert werden, damit einfach die Datalsystem-Strukturen wieder in Ordnung waren. Da kam man dann nicht mit Norton-Commander und hat irgendwie Repair gemacht, sondern einfach runterkopieren, wieder draufkopieren, halt das Datalsystem alles wieder gut. Weil da hat sich irgendwie alles zerfressen und so weiter. Naja, ich kopierte also die Daten wieder drauf, ich gab ihm den Laptop und er war glücklich und zog wieder von dann. Und ich saß da so und dachte mir so, ich kap Joseph Walzenbombs Computer repariert, das hab ich mir so eine Kerbe in meinem Lebensholz irgendwie, kann ich irgendwann mal von erzählen.
Und dann lag da die Festplatte, wo die Daten drauf?
Dann hatte ich ja noch die Daten auf meiner Festplatte. Und selbstverständlich habe ich diese Daten gelöscht. Bis auf eine Datei. Und sie guckte mich an und sagte, klick mich. Ich musste sie einfach anklicken, weil sie auf mich den Eindruck machte, dass sie genau das war, was sie dann auch am Ende war. Es handelte sich nämlich dabei um einen Test. Um einen Test von Josef Weizenbaum. Und er testete...
Ob du dir das anheilglaubst oder nicht?
Er testete das Mikrofon in seinem Laptop, was damals ja noch eine tolle Nummer war, dass man einen Computer hatte, in dem ein Mikrofon drin war. Und jeder von uns wird irgendwann mal, das erste Mal auf Rekord gedrückt haben, irgendwas in dieses Mikrofon gesprochen haben, um einen Test zu machen, um zu gucken, ob denn das so funktioniert. Und das war die Datei, die mich irgendwie anstarrte. Und ihr seid jetzt die ersten Menschen, die das hören. Und er sagte das.
Hier spricht Josef Weizenbaum.
Hab ich nie gelöscht.
Konnt ich nicht. Sorry. Der hörte ich eh nicht mehr.
Ja, aber ich wollte es halt mal erzählen irgendwie. Es war eigentlich nicht okay, aber ich konnte nicht anders. Ich dachte mir, das ist irgendwie ein Zeitdokument, das...
Guten Tag.
Sozusagen jetzt hier deine Beichte.
Das war mein Geständnis.
Also ihr gebt dem Tim keine Festplatte, schon gar nicht mit Audioaufnahmen.
Ja, dann haben wir einen Sendungstitel.
Das ist ja schon der zweite Sendungstitel.
So, wir könnten mal wieder mehr über Macs reden.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Das war doch schon eine Mac-Geschichte.
Stimmt, nicht so richtig. Na, es gibt Gerüchte. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie trägt.
Welche meinst du jetzt, welches Gerät oder um was geht's?
Na ja, zweitens, also erst mal gab es wieder so eine Patent-Veröffentlichung, die ja natürlich überhaupt nichts aussagt, aber schnell bei betroffenen Menschen das Herz zum Rasen bringt, wenn es darum geht, dass angekündigt wird, dass vielleicht LTE mein Laptop eingebaut werden könnte. Und genauso ein Patent hat Apple gerade mal wieder gegratet bekommen. Was auch immer man da neu erfinden kann, weil das gibt es ja nun irgendwie schon seit zehn oder zwanzig Jahren.
Was ist die Patent dafür, LTE in Laptop zu bauen?
Ja, nicht generell um LTE einzubauen, sondern auf die Art und Weise, wie sie es tun würden. Was auch immer patentierbar erscheint, Antennen, Tralala, links und... Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Mir ist es auch ehrlich gesagt, egal ob sie jetzt ein Patent dafür haben oder nicht, sie sollen es einfach mal machen. Ich finde diesen Zustand einfach unerträglich. Ich will irgendwie kein Gerät ohne LTE haben, kein Phone, kein Tablet, kein Laptop und auch keine Uhr. Alles muss LTE haben. LTE ist so wie WLAN. Das ist einfach eine Connectivity, die muss man haben. Die ist einfach erforderlich. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie davon abhält, aber vielleicht ist es die Sache mit den SIM-Karten. Vielleicht sehen sie jetzt auch den ersten Mute.
Oder vielleicht die Sache, dass das nicht alle so sehen wie du.
Das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Das hab ich auch das Gefühl.
Naja, dann geht die weitere Gerüchteküche in die Richtung, wie denn das neue MacBook Pro aussehen könnte. Und dass es dann vielleicht dieses Jahr auch schon so weit sei, dass wir ein neues sehen werden. Was ich ehrlich gesagt für ziemlich wahrscheinlich halte.
Wann war das letzte Jahr, März?
Naja, vom Formfaktor her hat sich jetzt schon...
Also du meinst so richtig neu, neu.
Jaja, nicht nur so neuer Prozessor.
Aber auch neuer Prozessor ist schon ewig her, oder?
Ja, das lag im Wesentlichen an Intel, die ja lange Zeit nicht geliefert haben.
Ich sag mal so, in zwei oder drei Wochen ist WWDC und wenn man die Entwicklergemeinde auf eine neue Prozessor-Architektur einschwören möchte, wäre das eine gute Gelegenheit.
Naja, wirklich ne neue Prozessor-Architektur ist ja nicht mehr der Entwickler, dem ist gar egal, ob der jetzt ein Skylake ist oder nicht. Wir glauben immer ja nicht, dass da ein Arm kommt. Außerdem kommt das erst nächstes Jahr, hab ich gesagt.
Also ich wäre sehr überrascht, wenn Sie jetzt Wechsel auf Arm verkünden würden.
Für das kleine MacBook macht das total Sinn, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, aber schon beim kleinen MacBook haben sie es nicht getan. Da ist jetzt einfach ein neuer Skylake-Prozessor drin, fertig aus.
Ja, weil du sowas nicht mal eben machst, selbst wenn du so eine gute Architektur hast, wie Apple dir das mal so eben erlaubt, so mit Universal Binaries und diesen ganzen Scheißen, die sie ja schon seit alten Open-Step-Tagen am Start haben.
Da sehe ich jetzt das geringste Problem, aber sie müssten natürlich schon, sollten sie tatsächlich jetzt einen Wechsel auf ARM-Prozessoren haben, dass sie ja mehr als nur Applications neu machen. Also es gibt ja auch viele Programme, oder manche zumindest im Profibereich, die jetzt auf Intel optimierten Code haben. Das weiß ich hier so.
Audio, Software, Treiberkram, High-Performance-Klimpe, da gibt es einfach viel, das ist halt heute einfach mal für Desktop und das ist einfach Intel-Assembler und das ist irgendwie feingetunt und das lässt sich mal nicht so von heute auf morgen auf Abend zu bringen. Das ist Apple am Ende egal, wenn sie klar sehen, dass das durchaus sich auch auf die andere Architektur übertragen lässt.
Außerdem ist es im meisten auch so Spezialsoftware, die dann auf diesen Low-Power-Geräten sowieso nicht wirklich ausgeführt wird.
Wenn du so ein kleines MacBook hast, dann machst du sowieso keine High-Performance-Sachen.
So sieht's aus. Dann muss der Browser funktionieren und noch...
Oder du hast sehr viel Geduld.
Ach wieso? Ich hab ein 2013er R, das neue MacBook ist in derselben Performance-Kategorie jetzt.
Genau, und das iPad Pro auch.
Ich mach damit aber High-End-Kram. Ich mach damit irgendwie Audio-Recording, ich rechne meine Audio-Files dadurch. Ich mach Encoding, Delcoding. Das Ding ist ganz schön unter Dampf. Also ich benutze das mit High-End-Software. Also ich sehe da jetzt nicht so das Argument. Also wenn sie die Architektur wechseln wollen, dann werden sie es auch einfach tun. Ob der Zeitpunkt jetzt schon gekommen ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, aber das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das, womit ich rechne. Und das ist auch nicht das, was jetzt sehr zeit...
Damit rechne ich auch nicht. Ehrlich gesagt.
Dass sie damit anfangen?
Nee, ich rechne nicht damit, dass sie für das MacBook Pro die Architektur wechseln.
Wenn sie die Architektur wechseln, dann wechseln sie sie generell.
Das kann ich mir auch wiederum nicht vorstellen.
Wenn irgendein Mac arm hat, dann werden alle Macs arm haben. Wenn sie nur bestimmte Geräte auf Arm umstellen, das... Nee, seh ich nicht.
Ich schon. Hat aber schon die Diskussion.
Hat mir schon mal so ein bisschen... Aber das ist ja auch gar nicht das, was jetzt gerade vermutet wird. Sondern es wird erst mal vermutet, es wird halt ein flaches MacBook Air. Also wie ein... Flacher als ein MacBook Air.
Ein Mac Pro. MacBook Pro.
Flacher als ein Air. Was dann so viel heißt wie USB-C. Könnte sogar sein, nur USB-C, viel USB-C und USB-C mit Thunderbolt 3, was ja auch in dieses Steckerformat reingeht. Das heißt, auch dieser Thunderbolt Stecker fällt weg. Eigentlich fällt alles weg. Das heißt, wir haben nur noch USB-C und machen über USB-C alles. Aber wenn das Ding halt auch nur einen Port hat, ich meine, dann können sie, glaube ich, können sie auch gleich wieder rausgehen.
Dann ist es aber auch kein Pro.
Dann ist es kein Pro, genau. Sondern es ist vielleicht ein Pro, wenn es sowas hat wie, jetzt die Frage, wie viele bräuchte man denn, um glücklich zu sein? Wie viele USB-C Stecker braucht man?
Also der deckt dann den Strom auch ab und das ist ja nett und alles, was USB-Voll war. Aber Audio hat er noch oder nicht?
Ja, Audio ist ja nochmal das andere große Fragezeichen, da haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Keine Ahnung.
Also in der Firma hab ich Strom, Netz, mindestens einen externen Monitor. Und einmal Tastatur und einmal Trackpad.
Ja gut, das kann man ja aber alles mit einem Connector machen. Das ist nämlich der Thunderbolt 3 und dein Bildschirm hat ein Ethernet, Tastatur, USB und alles, was du brauchst.
Meinst du, das ist so eine Docking-Situation? Ja, das machst du wirklich bei Thunderbolt.
Überall.
Da brauchst du nur einen Stecker.
Also kurz mal sagen, drei.
Ja, wenn du ein Thunderbolt-Monitor hast.
Also ich würd sagen, vier.
Ja.
Strom, Bildschirm, Netz und Device.
Und da ist dann der ganze Rest dran. Ein Bildschirm kann ein Dock sein. Find ich jedenfalls.
Ja im Prinzip schon, aber die Leute kaufen halt nicht alle ein Thunderbolt-Display von Apple.
Ja, das ist schon klar, aber Apple will gerne, dass alle Leute so ein Display kaufen.
Haben die denn jetzt überhaupt schon Retina-Displays? Die, die, ne, ne, ne, die externen Monitoren.
Warum auch immer, versteh ich auch nicht.
Dauert bestimmt auch nicht lange, bis sie sagen, wir stellen das ein.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass es kein Standard gibt, wo du so viele Pixel drüber kriegst, dass du damit ein ordentliches Retina 27 Zoll getrieben hast.
Wie sie verkaufen die anderen Firmen alle einen?
Ja, aber was macht der denn der? Der macht 4K, aber 4K ist ja jetzt nicht notwendigerweise Retina, oder? Also der Retina iMac sind halt 5K. Und 5K kriegst du über einen normalen Thunderbolt halt nicht rüber.
Aber Thunderbolt 3? Da müsste ja eigentlich in diese Richtung spezialisiert sein.
Habt ihr von diesem geilen neuen Dell-Monitor gehört, der ein 4K-Monitor ist und du kannst ihn als 4K-Monitor benutzen. Du kannst aber auch sagen, ich hätte gerne vier Mal HD-Bild und dann siehst du vier Bilder einzeln. Also er tut so, als wenn er vier Monitore ist im Quadrat angeordnet. Kennste nicht so Büros, da kommst du hin und dann haben die Leute da einen Bildschirm, da drüber einen, da neben einen und da drunter, also so vier Stück im Quadrat. Vier einzelne Bildschirme und dieser Dell macht das sozusagen als ein einziger Bildschirm und macht die drinnen virtuell aber ohne Naht, ohne Rahmen und so, sondern direkt.
So der Trick.
Also ich hab gerade mal gerade geguckt, Thunderbolt 3 ist im Prinzip doppelte Geschwindigkeit von Thunderbolt 2. Also 40 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Und 2 war doppelt verleiht.
Ja, wobei 1 ja auch 20 Gigabit, aber als zweimal 10 und Thunderbolt 2 war einmal 20. Zwei separate Kanäle. So, dass du darüber einmal HDMI einmal das machen konntest. Wie auch immer, Thunderbolt 3 ist doppelt so schnell und macht auch wieder PCI-Express-Displayport, hat 4 PCI-Express-Lanes, die du darauf legen kannst, oder 8 Displayport-Standard-Lanes oder 2 4K-Displays, die du da angeschlossen bekommst. Was dann wahrscheinlich auch so viel bedeutet, wie 1 5K sollte dann da auch irgendwie bei abfallen. Und wenn sie dann auch noch ihren Scheiß-iMac so hinkriegen, dass man den als externen Bildschirm betreiben kann, dann denke ich ja auch mal über einen Upgrade nach. Aber ich muss sagen, meine 2009er-Hardware, die bedient mich immer noch so fein. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt kein Kaufinstinkt derzeit. Und dann USB 3.1 ist halt damit dann dabei in dem ganzen 100 Watt Leistung für Strom und so weiter. Und 15 Watt gibt da raus und kann 10 Gigabit Internet machen. Ja, nehme ich. Also geringste Latenz für PCIe-Express-Audioaufnahme heißt es hier.
Stimmt.
Geringste Latenz heißt wie viel?
Also wenn du dir heute mal die Audio-Devices anschaust, die mit Thunderbolt kommen, die haben schon wirklich enorm niedrige Roundtrip-Zeiten. Das hängt dann natürlich auch immer ein bisschen von der Buffer-Size, von deiner Software ab.
Klar.
Also ich kann dir das mal kurz sagen, bei Focusrite gibt es für diese, wie heißen die Dinger? Clarett. Clarett Thunderbolt-Dinger haben die, und hier gab es irgendwo eine Tabelle. Da muss man aber noch zweimal klicken.
Erstmal schon geklickt.
Und zwar in Abhängigkeit von der Buffer-Size und natürlich auch in der Abhängigkeit der Sampling-Frequenz. Wobei sie jetzt hier nur 48 kHz.
Ja natürlich.
Was natürlich?
Es ist immer in Abhängigkeit von der Buffer-Size und der Sampling-Rate. Das ist irgendwie eine Null-Aussage.
Ja für dich. Aber wir reden ja hier mit vielen Menschen. Ich sag nur 48 kHz und 96 kHz ist das, was sie hier in der Tabelle haben. Obwohl die Dinger natürlich auch 192 kHz können. Und ich weiß gar nicht, warum sie das dann nicht auch noch mit anzeigen würden. Weil wenn das bedeutet, dass diese Talentenz noch mal geringer ist, sag ich nur hurra. Reaper, meine Software, mit einer Buffer-Size von 32 bytes, kommt auf Roundtrip von 1,68 ms. Das ist ganz gut. Das ist ganz gut, ja? Und das hätte ich auch wirklich sehr, sehr gerne. Ich hab hier sogar noch ein Thunderbolt-Interface, damit wollte ich nochmal testen, wie denn das eigentlich nur tatsächlich aussieht. Ja, und da gehe ich dann irgendwie auch mit, mit noch schneller und toller und so weiter, wenn sich das noch weiter limitieren lässt, umso besser. Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet, wenn ich, also bei der gleichen Buffer-Size von 48 kHz auf 96 kHz, bei Reaper komme ich halt von 2,6 auf 1,6. Wenn man halt 192 kHz anlegt, müsste das ja im Prinzip noch mal weniger sein. Das müsste ja dann schon fast an die Millisekunde rankommen.
Ja, das hängt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab, was so ein Protokoll-Overhead über Thunderbolt hast und so weiter.
Ja, das stimmt. Also kann ich auch nicht einschätzen, von der Datenmenge her soll das jetzt Thunderbolt nicht sonderlich beeindrucken. Ob dann nur ein paar Bits mehr rüberfliegen oder nicht.
Nee, nee, klar. Das sind halt eher so die Puffersachen, die du halt in dem ganzen Thunderbolt selber drin hast.
Aber das sind wirklich gute Zahlen. Abgesehen davon ist Reaper hier auch wirklich mit das Beste, zusammen mit Cubase und Logic. Dann gab es noch das Gerücht, dass die neuen MacBook Pros OLED Function Keys haben könnten.
Ich hoffe nicht irgendwie.
Das ist so nicht Apple wie irgendwas.
Ja, die Lenovo die letzten haben das ja irgendwie, ne? Das war, ich weiß nicht.
Haben was?
Also eine komische LED-Leiste, die so... Aber das sind gar nicht richtig LEDs. Ich glaube da ist auch so ein dunkles Band und da sind so Symbole drin, die können von unten beleuchtet werden, aber ich glaube die Symbole waren halt fix. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Auf jeden Fall war es nicht so schick, wie man es erst dachte und...
Ich meine, wenn Apple das macht, dann denke ich doch mal davon aus, dass die volle Funktionstaste so aussieht wie eine Apple Watch.
Die ganze Leiste meinst du so?
Jede einzelne, also die Tasten sind nach wie vor Tasten? Alles andere wäre ja wohl zum Verachten.
Da stand doch eine OLED-Bar, das heißt also so ein langer Streifen von Display.
Von Bar hab ich nichts gesagt, die ist halt nur OLED Function Keys, oder hab ich irgendwas von Leiste gesagt?
Nee, du nicht, aber der Text.
Entschuldigung, aber das ist so unglaublich.
Die Tasten, die wollen die loswerden, deswegen machen die ja so eine lange LED-Bar, weil das ist wahrscheinlich billiger, als die Tasten einzeln zu machen.
Ja, aber das ist so unglaubwürdig. Entschuldigung, aber das ist so unglaubwürdig.
Warum?
Weil das hässlich wird ohne Ende.
Was?
Ja.
Wieso?
Eine Reihe von Tasten, die alle unterschiedlich leuchten. Also das ist so...
Wie leuchtet? Na, da steht einfach was anderes drauf. So wie jetzt auch. Nur, dass es halt wie beim iPhone eine Softkeyboard ist, was, sagen wir mal, im Kontext der Anwendung, die du gerade verwendest, einfach mal sagt, was diese Scheißfunktionstaste macht.
So eine Watch-Complication hast du dann auf jeder einzelnen Taste?
Ja.
Glaub ich nicht.
Das fände ich fantastisch.
Ja, ist ein netter Gedanke, aber es... Das ist ein sehr teures Feature, was nicht allzu viel bringt.
Also, wenn du mitmachst, würde ich mit Timme um eine Kiste Mate wetten, dass es nicht klappt.
Ich sag nicht, dass es klappt. Ich sag nur, dass es das ist, was gewisse Weise kommt.
Wir beide wetten gegen dich um eine Kiste Mate, dass es nicht kommt.
Nee, dann mach ich nicht.
Gegen mich, gegen dich. Ja, ich glaub nicht, dass es gut kommt.
Das ist deine Chance, weil du kaufst sowieso immer Mate.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, das kommt. Ich hab nur gesagt, das wird gerüchtet. Und wenn so was käme, könnte ich das geil finden. Weil ich weiß ja, wie meine Apple Watch aussieht. Und die sind einfach mal geil aus.
Es wurde noch rumgeholt, dass sie keine Sekunden anzeigt.
Das hab ich ja selber in der Kontrolle. Hat ja auch nichts mit dem Bildschirm zu tun.
Wollten nur rumnageln.
Naja, ich weiß nicht.
Wir hatten das auch schon vor vielen Jahren. Da gab es auch schon dieses Tastaturprojekt.
Art Lebedev hieß die. Zweieinhalbtausend oder was die gekostet hat.
War das wirklich der Name?
Zweieinhalbtausend? Ach so, und die steht ja so in Momo und Staub voll, ne?
Diese Maximus Tastatur.
Ja, von dieser Firma Art Lebedev hießen die, glaube ich. Und da gab es dann nochmal diese...
Im Chat weiß einer, die haben so viele Apple Watches übrig, dass sie jetzt als das da sind.
Gab es das Ding eigentlich jemals oder?
Das gibt's.
Optimus, die kann man kaufen.
Die kann man kaufen, kostet aber unglaublich viel Geld und der ist meiner Meinung nach von zweifelhafter Anwendung.
1500 Dollar.
1500 Dollar ist ja billiger geworden.
Na ja, wie von zweifelhafter Anwendung.
Okay, es gibt inzwischen mehr davon.
Optimus, populares. Compact Keyboard with each key displaying any image and being assigned any function. Ich find das gut. Guck mal, da gibt's sogar eine Spacing-Wader-Taste drauf. Das ist natürlich für die Bedienung von Programmen, die einfach Spezialfunktionen haben, Photoshop, et cetera, zum Lernen einfach super. Und außerdem, man guckt immer die Funktionstasten an. Wie Apple sich seit Jahren da bemüht, da immer drauf zu schreiben, was die irgendwie gerade benutzen. Und dann ist das irgendwie jedes Mal wieder anders und dann weißt du nicht, mit welchem Modifier du das bedienst. Ich möchte gern ein Modifier drücken. Ich hätte gern jede Scheißtaste mit OLD. Nicht nur Funktionstasten. Jede Argument für Apple. Sie müssten dann noch weniger unterschiedliche Tastaturen herstellen.
Mein einer Kollege hat einfach seine gesamte Tastatur orange gemacht. Hat sich so eine Revellfarbe, so eine Revell, ich baue mein altes Kanonensiegelschiff zusammen, Farbe gekauft und hat sämtliche Tasten orange gemacht, weil er orange geil findet.
Im Chat wäre man gerade missverstanden, als ob wir hier von Soft-Tastaturen reden. Nee, ich rede hier von einer normalen Tastatur mit richtigen Tasten, wo aber nicht einfach nur ein hintergrundbeleuchteter, fester Buchstabe drauf ist, sondern wo einfach die ganze Scheiß-Taste so ein Display ist.
Ja, hast du voll vergessen. Da ist gar kein Platz. Die wollen alles dünner machen und du willst da noch ein Display einbauen in der Taster?
Aber reden sie jetzt seit Jahren davon, wie geil OLED ist und worum du das überall rumlegen kannst und wie dünn das ist und so?
Ja, aber nicht Apple.
Sollen sie mal liefern? Ja, die kaufen das doch eh nur ein. Wir werden es sehen.
Ich find's gut.
Ich hab schon die hintergrundbeleuchtete Tastatur war ja schon so ein Schritt nach vorne.
Das fand ich damals allerdings auch sehr, sehr geil.
Das war so richtig so dieses Gefühl.
Ich war mittags bei meiner Desktop-Tastatur.
So abends im Park, wenn niemand mehr was gesehen hat.
Genau, dass die Desktop-Tastatur das nicht hat, das ist auch irgendwie beknackt. Jede Tastatur muss so was sein.
Als wenn man in der Hellen arbeiten würde, als Nerd.
Genau, Simulation. Na ja gut, wir werden sehen, wie das hier alles so einfällt. Wann ist denn eigentlich die W-W-D-Te?
Ich glaube, in drei Wochen.
In drei Wochen. Eins, zwei, drei. Du hast du recht. Das heißt, wir werden noch eine Sendung haben, wo wir uns noch mit etwas frischeren Gerüchten aufhalten können.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass sie zur WWDC irgendwelche Hardware rausbringen.
Nicht, dass sie das nicht schon mal getan hätten.
Ja, aber das letzte Mal ist fünf Jahre her.
Das bringen sie ja wieder eine neue Maus raus.
Oder kleben wieder jedem eine Webcam unter den Stuhl.
Ich hab meine Eyesight immer noch. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ob die überhaupt noch unterstützt wird.
Da fällt mir gerade ein, weil sollten wir das mal on air machen. Und zwar der Termin für die übernächste Sendung, die wir derzeit im Kalender stehen haben, ist der 22.
Juni.
Ja, muss mir das was sagen?
Sag mal Dinge ins...
Ja, der 22. Juni ist... Na ja, es ist jetzt einfach bald Europameisterschaft.
Echt?
Fußball, also um genau zu sein...
Da dieses Ding in Frankreich, wo sie den Ball hinten hält.
Fußball Europameisterschaft der Herren. Und am 22. Juni würde während unserer Sendung die Spiele, oder werden sogar, nicht nur würden, sondern werden die Spiele Italien gegen die Republik Irland und Schweden gegen Belgien laufen.
Jetzt ist das spannend, können wir Sendung machen.
Können wir Sendung machen.
Oder?
Dachte ich mir auch, habe ich mal den Termin reingelegt. Zwei Wochen später wird es aber ein bisschen kniffliger, weil dann ist Halbfinale. Das ist die Frage.
Ja, werden wir auch in zwei Wochen nicht wissen, richtig? Und werden wir auch am 22. dann noch nicht wissen?
Ähm, nein, das ist halt schwierig vorher zu sagen. Die Frage ist, verlegen wir die Sendung auf einen anderen Tag?
Ja, du bist hier der Sendeschef.
Ihr sagt ja immer, ihr habt keine Zeit. Aber ich würde sagen, Halbfinale, da schneiden wir uns ins eigene Fleisch.
Aber guck mal, wenn die Deutschen rausfliegen früh.
Ist trotzdem eine Halbfinale.
Hat man wenigstens eine Sache, worüber man sich freuen kann?
Sendung.
Ach so. Verstehe. So, Robin.
Spielen denn die Engländer mit?
Ja.
Du kennst den Witz, ne? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem englischen Fußball-Team und dem englischen Frühstück? Der Frühstück bleibt länger in der Karte.
Wobei wir ja gerade ein ganz emsiges Team beisammen.
Wir vor allen Dingen, ne? Na ja gut, darfst du sagen. Prost.
Ich hab nicht wir gesagt.
Die Briten, die Engländer, so rum.
Briten hat das nix zu tun. Die Briten gibt es nicht.
Deswegen hab ich ja mit dem Fußball verbessert. Die Engländer.
Wird es nie geben. Das ist einfach vollkommen unvorstellbar. Also wahrscheinlich gibt's früher... Nee, dann auch nicht.
Die Schotten, haben die auch ihr eigenes Team am Start?
Bitte dich.
Eleven players.
Die Schotten haben das mit dem Fußball erfunden. Selbstverständlich haben die Schotten ein Team.
Aber sind sie qualifiziert, meine ich, für die EM?
Nein.
Das ist die Frage.
Das ist halt das Drama. Dass die Schotten leider ihre Erfolge der ersten Jahre nicht anknüpfen können. Lustigerweise sind aber alle anderen britischen Teams dabei. Einschließlich Nordirland und Wales.
Echt, ja?
Ja, nur Schottland hat es nicht geschafft.
Das ist natürlich eine harte Nummer.
Harte Nummer, ja. Das ist wirklich eine harte Nummer.
Also wir werden eventuell Nordirland gegen Republik Irland sehen?
Ja, denkbar. Die haben ja eigentlich miteinander nicht so viel zu tun. Aber Nordirland gegen Wales oder sowas oder gegen England, das ist ein richtiges Ding. Irland ist ja Ausland.
Na ja, aber die mögen sich halt nur so mittelmäßig.
Aber die sind sich immer noch näher als Nordirn und die Engländer. Macht das dann mal keine Illusionen. Wenn sich irgendjemand hasst bis aufs Blut, dann ist es wirklich das britische Volk untereinander.
Man muss nur Trainspotting gucken, ne?
Ja, da weiß man eigentlich immer alles Bescheid. Also ehrlich gesagt, der Rest hier ist blar. Was ich hier noch auf meiner Liste habe. Müssen wir nicht machen.
Blar?
Auf deiner Workiflowi?
Ich hatte jetzt hier im besten Fall noch so ein absurdes Kickstarter-Projekt, das ich irgendwie gesehen habe, was ich irgendwie ganz lustig fand. Das muss ich ja nochmal zeigen. Nicht, dass ich das jetzt irgendwie endorsen würde, weil ich bin ja auch nicht so ein Typ für... Aber die Idee fand ich dann schon ziemlich geil. Und zwar, wir haben es ja immer so mit unseren Rucksäcken, und das Projekt heißt MOV-Pack. Und es ist ein Rucksack mit eingebautem Skateboard.
Das heißt, man muss den gar nicht einpacken, sondern muss den nur hochklappen, weil der Rucksack immer am Skateboard dran bleibt.
Aber sehe ich das richtig? Electric Vehicle steht da, ne?
Ja, richtig. Und das hat auch noch ein Akku in diesem Rucksack und quasi einen E-Motor. Das heißt, du kannst einen Rucksack tragen, klappst das Skateboard quasi an der Innenseite des Rucksacks irgendwie hoch, kannst dann so dummdumdumdumdum durch die Gegend latschen. Und wenn du halt Transport brauchst, setzt du deinen Rucksack kurz ab, klappst das Skateboard aus, stellst dich drauf und dann bleibt halt der Rucksack auch auf dem hinteren Teil des Skateboards. Ich kann euch das ja gerne mal hier kurz zeigen hier. Das ist jetzt ein edentlanges Video.
Oh Gott, diese. Dramatik. Oder, wenn du mehr als nur ein Backpack hast, sind das alle Herausforderungen, die die Mieter haben. Das ist warum wir die beste Lösung für den ursprünglichen Mieter gegründet haben. Mit Farbe, Dino.
Sie sehen die bekloppt aus.
We've re-engineered MovePack to implement not one but two motors inside the wheel.
Wir haben dir jetzt noch einen draufgelegt, aber ich fand das einfach extrem bemerkenswert, einfach diese Idee schon mal zu haben, so einen Rucksack zu kombinieren mit Transport. Weil das ist eigentlich ganz cool, weil der Rucksack bleibt ja dann auch fest hinten drauf, ne?
Der kann nicht runterfallen.
Er kann dann wohl nicht runterfallen, also ob man da jetzt wirklich ein stabiles Fahrerlebnis hinbekommt, weiß ich nicht, aber dass das Ding dann halt auch noch elektrisch ist und du dann so mit der Fernmitte nun durch die Gegend düsen kannst, ist schon irgendwie cool.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das ist doch was für Leute, die sich auf dem Segway noch nicht blöd genug aussehen.
Ach so, den Lautsprecher haben sie glaube ich auch noch drin.
Wie viel passt da wirklich dann rein, wenn du noch...
Und Ladegerät.
Passt da nur noch dein Handy rein?
Ja, ich würde bei der Serie natürlich auch dein Telefon aufladen.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist das ja auch alles bekloppt, aber warum nicht? Also ich finde gerade die Elektromobilität hat ja wirklich eine ganze Menge so an angenehmen Effekten, wie zum Beispiel dieses extrem kompakte Durch-die-Gegen-Gefahren. Ich fahre ja hier auch jetzt seit einem anderthalb Jahr mit meinem Elektroroller durch die Gegend und ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein Happy-E-Roller geworden. Das ist irgendwie geil. Also das erschließt meinen Kiez im Umfeld von sagen wir mal so zwei, drei Kilometern ganz wunderbar. Kann man auch als richtigen Rucksack benutzen. Zeigen sie gerade hier. Wenn man die ganzen Innereien einfach rausnimmt. Ein Tausend-Zasar.
Das Sport weglässt.
Top Speed 20 Meilen pro Stunde.
Die Frage ist, ob man noch skaten kann ohne Rucksack.
Ne, wahrscheinlich nicht.
So cheesy.
Oh Gott, ist das cheesy.
Okay, für 900 Dollar Movepack Indie Go Go Special.
700 Dollar, nicht 900.
700. Stimmt. Will Retail 1200. You save 501.
Na ja, gut.
Ob man sich wirklich was spart oder nicht am Ende einfach nur Geld für Dinge ausgibt, die man am Ende nicht braucht, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich finde einfach diesen Trend sehr schön.
Eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich nicht?
Noch ein kleiner Newsflash. ZFS gibt zumindest für US-Tenden ein Update. Ist jetzt nichts Großes oder so, aber falls es irgendwie untergegangen ist.
Dann ist es jetzt nicht mehr untergegangen.
Genau, weil so oft passiert ja da nix und deswegen guckt wahrscheinlich auch nicht jeder jeden Tag da. Andere Newsflashes, heute gab es Updates, oder gestern schon, ne, heute glaube ich für die Apple Airport Express und Xtreme und wie heißt das andere Ding? Dieses Backup? Time Capsule gab es irgendwie Updates heute.
Mir ist es nicht kaputt gegangen. Ich finde die Backups nicht mehr.
Du findest die nicht mehr.
Als ich im Urlaub war, dachte ich mir so, okay, schön über Strom ausstellen und als ich wieder kam, dachte ich mir, okay, machen wir erstmal wieder alles an und dann sagte mir meine Time Machine so, hast du hier deine Backups? Die finde ich nicht. Und sagte aber erstmal, dass bei den Backups alles in Ordnung ist und dann so ein kleingedruckten, so eigentlich ist nichts in Ordnung und du kannst jetzt hier auf formatieren, klicken und all deine alten Backups sind weg.
Also Verification failed kam da, richtig?
Genau.
Ja, das kenne ich. Das hat das irgendwie manchmal, da musst du komplett von vorne anfangen. Das ist natürlich blöd, weil in dem Augenblick, wo du von vorne anfängst, hast du für die Zeit zumindest, wo du das neue Backup machst, erstmal kein Backup mehr. Und wenn was auf deinem Rechner kaputt ist oder so, ist es weg.
Ja, ich glaube ich werde deswegen auch einfach wieder weggehen davon.
Ja, ich glaube auch gegen dieses Verification failed gab es jetzt auch noch keine Lösung, dass man irgendwie sagt, nee, nee, das gab es nicht.
Ja, doch, es gibt da so einen Blogpost von einem, der sagt, wie man das reparieren kann, wo du im Prinzip das Image dann mountest und dann ein längliches Fallsystem checken machst und dann das irgendwie in irgendeiner P-Liste dann einfach änderst und so weiter.
Den will ich mal noch versuchen.
Ja, das kannst du machen, aber es dauert Stunden. Also das ist wirklich, weil er halt einmal alles durchnodelt.
Auf der Time Capsule, ja?
Warte, warte, warte, wir haben eine, ist das jetzt, ich glaube wir haben so ein Airport Extreme Ding, wo die Festplatte noch drin ist? So ein Ding haben wir.
Ansonsten hast du ein Airport Extreme und da hast du deine Festplatte über USB angeschlossen.
Nee, dann ist es dann halt die Time Capsule.
Die Festplatte ist direkt drin, dann ist es eine Time Capsule.
Klassiker, ich habe da schon so viele Backups komplett abgegeben, ich wusste es nicht, das ist der Hammer. Das kannst du komplett vergessen, das ist irgendwie eines der schlechtesten Produkte, die Apple je herausgebracht hat.
Das ist halt, weil er verlegt da ein Disk-Image an und unter irgendwelchen Bedingungen gründen kann halt dieses Disk-Image irgendwie kaputt gehen. Und meistens kriegt man es aber repariert und das ist halt das Absurde da dran. Also nicht, dass es dann da den Button gibt, ne, dann versuch doch jetzt mal zu reparieren, ne, aber du kannst so mit Boardmitteln und HDI, OTIL und allem drum und dran, kannst du es meistens wieder hinkriegen.
Ja, aber du musst dann halt das Teil auseinander bauen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ne, ne, ne, das musst du nicht. Das Problem, weil es nicht nur das noch andere Daten auf der Time-Kipsel sind, nicht nur meine. Also Nils muss seine Sachen erstmal darunter...
Warte mal, wie, man muss das Ding nicht auseinander bauen, um an die Platte ranzukommen?
Wie wird sie denn repariert?
Ja, ja, mountest ja die Platte einfach.
Wie denn?
Naja, über Netzwerk.
Ja, das ging ja schon nicht mehr irgendwie.
Ja, dann hast du eine von denen erwischt, die hardwaremäßig einfach über den Jordan gegangen sind. Da gab es ja auch genug von der ersten Generation Time-Capsule.
Hast du eine Time-Capsule, die du nicht mehr brauchst?
Die gestorben sind, weil sie zu heiß sind.
Ich habe eine Time-Capsule, die irgendwo noch rumsteht.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob die gerade noch gebraucht werden.
Also wenn jemand Time-Capsule hat und keinen Bock mehr auf die, ich würde gerne mal eine probieren, weil ich habe keine.
Richtig.
Weil ich mache mein Backup hier auf wie BFZFS und da drauf, dann halt hier mit Netatalk so Apple Style auch über Web automatisch. Also nicht über Web-WLAN, aber eine Time-Capsule selbst habe ich noch nie probiert. Und man kann die ja als als 2. oder 3. Backup reinhängen. Das heißt, es ist hier dann auch nichts. So vor, ich sehe so langsam in der Zeit. Noch schlimmer?
Das ist so schlimm.
Wie gesagt, wenn einer eine hat, her damit. Von mir aus auch gerne ohne Platte.
Also mir ist neulich eine Backup Festplatte. Also ich habe nicht nur halt auf dem Server, sondern halt auch so kleine zweieinhalb Zoll Festplatten. Die hingen dann noch so am Rechner. Ich nehme so den Rechner vom Tisch. Und dann baumelte die da noch eine Sekunde. Und dann so bang, fiel sie runter. Naja, der Prit-Lasche-Hörtest, der gab nur so ein Klack-Click, Klack-Click, Klack-Click, Klack-Click und ja.
Tonne.
Das war's. Genau, das war's. Also, da hilft auch das beste Dateisystem.
Achso, es gibt noch ZFS-News. Und zwar hat einer sich angeguckt, wie die noch zu Orakel-Zeiten oder damals sogar noch Sun-Zeiten, wie die ja Encryption für ZFS gemacht haben, code, weiß nicht, ob da eine code released wurde, aber dieser Typ, der das gemacht hat, der hat zumindest so ein bisschen in so Blogposts erzählt, was er, wie wo speichert und wie sein Design sozusagen ist und schon auch ein bisschen genauer. Und da hat sich jetzt ein Typ hingesetzt und hat Encryption so implementiert, wie der das damals auch schon für Orakel so implementiert hat. Also, ist wahrscheinlich nicht kompatibel, aber so im Großen und Ganzen hat er zumindest das Design übernommen. Und der Typ, der wiederum den ZFS-Port für US-10 macht, der wollte das halt nicht auf Linux testen und hat das halt auch gleich mal unter US-10 irgendwie übernommen. Und da testen wir jetzt gerade rum. Es ist halt die Frage, ob das dann angenommen wird und ob es übernommen wird, weil es ist ja erstmal nur so ein Projekt von einem so Typen, aber es sieht wohl alles ganz gut aus. Und wenn alles schick ist und läuft und überhaupt, dann haben wir vielleicht im halben Jahr oder in einem Jahr haben wir ZFS mit Krypto. Und dann ist das pro Dataset, wer das richtig verstanden hat. Das heißt, du kannst einen Pool haben, von dem du bootest, aber dann gibt es halt den Datapool, den man erst mit Passwort mounten muss und sonst nicht rankommt.
Pro Dataset heißt das Pool, oder?
Pro Filesystem. Pool ist ja sehr viel, genau. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Und das war wohl aber auch so, dass Metadaten waren wohl nicht verschlüsselt, aber Daten schon. Also das heißt, Pfeilnamen natürlich sieht man auch nicht. Das sind ja auch theoretisch Metadaten, aber ist mehr so, die sieht man auch nicht. Aber alles, was Pool ist oder Pfeilsystem-mäßig ist, da sieht man natürlich. Aber wenn es weiter reingeht, ist es dann verschlüsselt.
Ok, also Krypto fehlt noch komplett auch bei FreeBSD, ne?
Ne, ne, ne, Krypto gibt es schon. Das macht man bei FreeBSD, indem man darunter ein sogenanntes Geli irgendwie benutzt. Das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen wie bei diesem Core Storage, wo halt du sagst, hier, ich habe folgende Festplatte, machen wir mal da die folgende Partition, machst du mir einmal so ein Geli-Encryption und dann entsteht ein neues Device, was halt gekryptet ist und da auf diesem Device installierst du dann dein ZFS.
Das heißt, ja, aber das ist doch ein bisschen falsch rum, oder?
Naja, aber es funktioniert wohl ziemlich gut.
In der ZFS denke ich natürlich schon, ja, man will es im ZFS haben und nicht darunter.
Ja, aber der Vorteil ist, dass du nur das Encryption unten drunter hast, dass halt man von dem ZFS gar nichts sieht, also weder Pool-Namen noch irgendwas und deswegen der Nachteil ist natürlich, dass dieses Gehli ist nicht kompatibel oder portierbar auf andere Plattformen und das heißt, wenn die sich auch bei ZFS jetzt auf diesen Encryption, werden sich da alle einigen, also zumindest alle aus Auraque, weil die haben es ja bei sich schon, aber hier Linux, ElumOS und Delphi und OS X und so und FreeBSD vor allem, dann wäre das natürlich eine coole Sache. Also Schaden kann es nicht, muss man mal gucken, was da kommt. Und performance- mäßig, also so wie Compression über die heutigen Cores der CPUs, kein Problem, es sollte Krypto ja mit AES-NI und so weiter, sollte auch alles kein Problem mehr sein. Also ich denke mal, performance-mäßig merkt man überhaupt gar nichts.
Also ich nehme das gern, wenn es kommt. Wo wir jetzt gerade so auf diesem Kernelfallsystem-Level sind, das ist jetzt auch keine große Meldung, aber Dropbox kommt jetzt. Dropbox hat angekündigt, dass sie ihre Software- Architektur umstellen von ihrer Extension und jetzt wollen sie irgendwie richtig in den Kernel gehen. Also sozusagen so richtig Dropbox-Fallsystem- Kernel-Extension in den Kernel einbauen, weil sie sich dann so Fuse, Hooks und so weiter ersparen und dadurch halt bessere Performance bringen können. Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin auch schon echt kurz davor, irgendwie Dropbox noch zu überdenken, zumindest so für mein Working Set, weil diese Software, die sie da ausliefern, die ist ja so dermaßen unperformant. Das geht überhaupt nicht. Also, ich hab hier einen Rechner, den schalte ich halt mal halt auch ein paar Tage mal aus und dann kommt er halt hoch und dann muss er sich irgendwie sünken und dann dauert das stundenlang, zieht dieser Prozess 100 Prozent CPU, wo ich schon erstmal finde, so wenn schon CPU, warum dann nicht die ganzen 800 Prozent, die theoretisch in Verfügung stehen? Also wenn du schon irgendwie so viel Energie brauchst, dann nimm doch zumindest schon mal alles, damit es schneller geht. Aber warum braucht überhaupt etwas, was mit Fallsystemen arbeitet und sich irgendwie mit dem Internet verständigt? 100 Prozent CPU. Also mir fällt überhaupt gar kein Szenario ein, in der eine Software die vollständige CPU benötigt, um ein Syncing mit dem Internet zu machen, oder?
Naja gut, also das erste, was sie machen werden, ist sämtliche Dateien, die sie noch nicht kennen, halt mal zu fingerprinten mit irgendeinem Char, sonst was. Aber auch da sollte man eigentlich keine 100 Prozent brauchen, sondern vielleicht eine 100 Prozent Festplatten-Auslastung.
Außerdem, wenn sich an seiner Dropbox nichts geändert hat, müssen sie ja auch eigentlich nichts neu haschen, oder doch? Oder wie?
Aber 100 Prozent CPU, was auf der Platte und im Netz arbeitet, das kann mir keiner erzählen.
Das haben sie auch so einen Spinning-Glock. Aber vielleicht ist ja wirklich dieser Fuse-Code so schlecht und dass sie deswegen wirklich sagen, sie haben halt eine Weile geguckt und haben gesehen, alles klar, Fuse ist schuld und wir gehen jetzt mal da weg und machen es halt mal selber richtig.
Ja, es kann sein, dass sie so viele Kontext-Switcher haben, dass das irgendwie macht. Trotzdem ist es nicht egal.
Ja, aber Kontext-Switch, also so viele Kontext-Switch zu machen, dass du 100 Prozent CPU machst, dann also...
Ich hab da auch keine gute Erklärung dafür.
Ja, BT Sync ist das Einzige, was hilft.
Ja, BT Sync, BitTorrent Sync nutze ich auch, hat aber eben nicht so... Dem fehlt halt so ein bisschen die Cloud-Komponente, die manchmal auch ganz praktisch ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich fand BT Sync auch immer noch ein bisschen irgendwie komisch zu bedienen. Das war immer irgendwie nicht so...
Ja, es ist viel besser geworden.
Na, seit zwei ist es aber gut, finde ich.
Es ist händelbar, es ist nicht problemfrei, aber wenn es mal anfängt zu Syncing, ist es halt extrem schnell. Also, Beton Sync muss man sagen, ist schon wirklich ein echter Feger. Im Vergleich zu Dropbox spielt das in einer komplett anderen, ja genau, insbesondere Lokal. Da ist es so richtig geil. Ich meine, ich mach hier zum Beispiel den Luxus, dass alles, was ich jetzt hier gerade aufnehme, wird während ich hier noch aufnehme.
Schon Beton Sync auf dem Server?
Auf verschiedene Rechner. Du hast auch den Vorteil, dass wenn ich unterwegs bin und in irgendwelchen anderen Städten bin und WLAN hab, dann lasse ich halt das Beton Sync auch laufen. Da habe ich quasi während der Aufnahme schon so einen Echtzeit-Backup. Also in der Regel, wenn ich den Rechner am Schluss zuklappe, ist im Prinzip die Sendung schon auf vier Rechnern distributiert. Was einfach den Vorteil hat, ich muss ja immer damit rechnen, was weiß ich, dass mir immer halt, keine Ahnung, Rechner geklaut, verloren, kaputt, was auch immer, kann ja immer was passieren. Und so ist es halt einfach schon mal verteilt. Das ist in der Tat ein cooles Feature und das geht ziemlich effizient. Dropbox hat dann wiederum den Vorteil, du kannst halt, wenn du jetzt nur so mit zwei Rechnern arbeitest, die nicht immer gleichzeitig online sind, so funktioniert das halt auch noch. Machs halt, weil du einen Pseudo dritten Rechner hast. Genau, du hast immer noch diesen Rechner in der Cloud und der hat es dann schon mal zu klappen, anderen später aufklappen und dann kommen die Daten irgendwo her. Und ich hab immer wieder bei BitTorrent Sync so dieses, oh jetzt läuft der BitTorrent Sync-Prozess auf dem Rechner gerade nicht, weil, keine Ahnung, User ausgelockt und so weiter.
Ich hab benutztes BitTorrent Sync eigentlich gerne mit dem Nifty Drive zusammen. Also ich hab ja dieses Nifty Drive da immer im SD-Karten-Slot drin, 128 Gig. Und das ist halt ein großes BitTorrent Sync-Share, was dann immer auf den Server synkt und ich pack da immer alles drauf, was irgendwie nicht schnell sein muss, irgendwelche Videos, die irgendwo rausfallen oder sonstiges Zeug, was ich mir später angucken will. Und das Schöne ist, dass ich dann aber auf dem Server sagen kann, okay, das hab ich alles gesehen, das pack ich jetzt woanders hin und dann wird es aber im Umkehrschluss auch aus diesem Ding wieder rausgesynkt. Also es ist dann halt wieder weg und dann hab ich wieder Platz. Ohne dass ich mir jetzt Gedanken machen muss, wo ist jetzt was und wie und das muss das nicht bei Handsynken. Find ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Jaja, das ist schon ziemlich praktisch.
Okay, dann müssen wir eigentlich nur noch über Star Wars reden. Habt ihr das aktuelle Internet-Mem-Dijour schon mitbekommen?
Ja, aber ich hab nur ungefähr drei Bildschirme seitenweit gescrollt.
Echt? Du hast das Video nicht gesehen?
Meinst du jetzt Chewbacca-Mam, ja?
Ja.
Das hab ich nicht gesehen.
Das nicht.
Da hab ich immer irgendwie, wenn schon alle hypen, hab ich schon mal gar keinen Bock mehr.
Du hast das auch nicht gesehen?
Echt nicht?
Wozu? Ist da irgendwas Wichtiges drin, was sich sonst in meinem Leben irgendwie, wo mir was entgeht?
Ja.
Glaub ich immer nicht so richtig. Und Letty, hast du das gesehen?
Bacca, nicht Bäcker.
Ist egal, das findet man.
So, ist das irgendwie... Wo ist denn der Mitte?
Was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Ach so, ich hab Chewbacca falsch geschrieben. So, gucken wir mal, welches hier der ist, genau.
Drei Millionen auf, wo ist denn noch nicht so viel? Ach so, ist ja auch nicht verhältlich.
Ja, vier Millionen muss ich jetzt nicht komplett abspielen. So, wieso ist das so leise?
Echt, das habt ihr noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist Candice. Also jemand, der so aus einer ganz eigenen, natürlichen Begeisterung heraus einfach freudig ist.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Und zwar, also sie redet jetzt viel darüber, was sie sich gekauft hat. Und sie hat sich halt gekauft eine Maske, eine Chewbacca-Maske.
Eine Maske mit eingebauten Lautsprecher.
Und sie geht total ab.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist sie jetzt total der Hype irgendwie.
Sie war schon irgendwie bei Facebook eingeladen, läuft von einer TV-Show zu nächsten. Wie das heißt, das ist in Amerika, wenn sie erstmal jemanden entdeckt haben, dann wird das halt auch immer total, aber es ist einfach ein grandioser Spaß.
So Candice, berichte doch mal von dem Moment, wie war das jetzt im Auto genau? Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, wie man da so ein Riesending draus macht.
Da ist mir dann aber was anderes eingefallen. Und zwar dieser Sound, dieser Chewbacca-Sound. Ich hab mir mal so ein Chewbacca-Sound-Board organisiert.
Ist das nicht geil?
Ich muss sagen, ich fand diesen Sound, den sie da designt haben, diesen Chewbacca-Sound, also wie dieses Viech einfach klingt, fand ich schon immer grandios.
Ja, der Chewbacca war schon immer cool irgendwie, gerade weil er immer die Klappe hält.
Aber die eigentliche Frage ist ja immer, wie kriegt man das hin, diesen Sound zu imitieren? Da gibt es dann irgendwie so ein schönes Tutorial, das ist schon so ein bisschen älter, wo jemand das mal erklärt.
Ich hab nur ein Chubaka Tutorial gesehen und es ist komplett falsch. In diesem Video sagen sie dir, etwas zu benutzen, das Umbula, das schmutzige Ding in der Mitte deiner Hände. Ich hab News für dich. Schritt 1. Und fühl dich frei, deine eigenen Varianten zu bewerben. Und noch einmal. Das war Bray Days. I'm peacein out.
Ja, das fiel mir in dem Zusammenhang wieder ein.
Hab ich euch letztens schon erzählt, dass mein Chewbacca muss mir angucken, falls er mal einen Schauspieler gesehen hat. Haben wir uns in der Sendung den Chewbacca-Schauspieler angeguckt?
Wie angeguckt?
Da wäre der ein Schauspieler.
Na, der ist halt mal der selber, ne?
Also, wenn man sich vermiesen will, dann guckt man jetzt, wie der Schauspieler aussieht, der Schubacca spielt.
Was vermisst man sich denn damit?
Na, du kannst nie wieder Star Wars angucken. Du siehst dann immer den Schauspieler und nicht mehr Chewbacca. Richtig. Ja, weil das sieht witzig aus.
Das ist doch kein Fehler.
Nee, aber den sieht man halt auch, wenn man Chewbacca sieht, verstehst? Du musst dir so vorstellen, als wenn, stell dir vor, Woody Allen hätte immer Darth Vader gespielt und du weißt es nicht.
Oh Gott, alles ist vorbei.
Genau, aber um euch zu erlösen, ist ja nicht so. Woody Allen hat nicht Darth Vader gespielt. Genau, es war Charlie Chaplin. Nein, aber der Typ, der Chewbacca spielt, der sieht schon auch sehr witzig aus. Und ich guck jetzt nochmal. Hector Chewbacca. Und der hat ihn auch immer beim neuen immer noch gespielt.
Ja, es war sehr überrascht. Und C3PO, ich dachte ja, bei dem neuen Star Wars war alles anders, aber es war nicht alles anders. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie die Leute das schaffen über so einen langen Zeitraum.
Mist, hier sieht er ja noch relativ normal aus, der Typ. Aber ein Bild, da dachte ich auch... Oder war das die Wikipedia-Seite? Na ja, jedenfalls müsst ihr mal gucken, dann habt ihr Spaß.
Chewie. Wo wir noch bei Star Wars sind, da tippt ihr mal ein. SWANHNET SWANHNET Star Wars A New Hope Genau, Star Wars A New Hope, SWANHNET Das ist wieder eins von diesen Projekten, wo man sich denkt, habt ihr sie noch alle? Da hat dann jemand irgendwie so ein...
Wie nannten sie das? Infografik?
Ja, so ein Webseiten-Scroller. Das Feldwerk, was da zum Einsatz kommt?
Oder die Technik?
Die Technik.
Ach echt?
Der hat den ganzen Film so durch Runterscrollen abgebildet oder wie?
Der komplette Film Star Wars 4, A New Hope. Jedes Detail, jeder Dialog, jede einzelne Szene ist hier in so einem Infographics-Style. Ja, einschließlich der allen beteiligten Personen, jeder, wie das Wort was gesagt wird, wo die sich dann gerade in dem jeweiligen Raum befinden und so weiter. Sogar der Download von uns. Genau, die haben alle einen Knall. Du kannst dich einfach hier stundenlang durch diesen ganzen Film durchscrollen. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Und ja, es nimmt irgendwie kein Ende. Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Projekt ist, aber es ist einfach amazing. Das zeigt mir aber auch immer wieder, dass Star Wars eigentlich schon echt einfach the most beloved movie ever ist.
Weil das findest du einfach, diese Dichte, eine Hingabe, da kommt irgendwie Star Trek nicht mit.
Kann man mal so festhalten, oder? Also nur so mal so rein von den Fakten her. Ich sag das, betone das natürlich gerne, weil ich bin ja auch mehr so ein Star Wars Typ.
So ein bisschen.
Ich bin so ein Star Wars und so ein Twitter Typ. Das bin ich. Das hätte auch auf Star Trek und Facebook hinauslaufen können.
Gibt's dieses Tellnet Star Wars?
Wirklich?
Star Wars lässt dich kalt?
Ich fand auch den neuen Teil jetzt nicht so.
Gibt's dieses Tellnet Star Wars eigentlich noch?
Im Übrigen wurde mir schon häufig gesagt, dass ich auch so ein Geräusch machen kann wie Tobacca.
War das ein Kompliment?
Ja, derjenige meinte das nett. Irgendwie auf Arbeit, keine Ahnung, was ich manchmal dafür Geräusche mache.
Ich werde auch noch mal nachfragen, nachdem ich die ganzen Videos gesehen habe.
Du hast Star Wars nicht gesehen?
Nee, also ich hab's glaub ich mal versucht mit eingeschlafen. Sorry, aber das ging mir schon mit mehreren Filmen so. Ich bin eher so der Buchtyp, sorry.
Ich hab da schon mal so eine andere Filmlücke geschlossen bei dir, das hast du nicht gewollt.
Nee, aber, dass ich jetzt sage, hat die Welt verändert, sorry, es fehlt leider.
Versteht man die Hälfte der Memen nicht? Lassen wir das. So wie zum Thema Star Wars, man kann durchscrollen und wer den Film sowieso schon auswendig kennt, kann sich jetzt hier sozusagen versichern, dass kein Detail entgangen ist.
So wie zu Star Wars.
Wann kommt eigentlich der nächste raus, oder ist es Rogue One oder so, das ist ja so ein Offspring, wie man das nennt.
Spin-Off.
The Offspring war was anderes.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber das wirst du sicherlich schnell erklickt bekommen. So, kleiner Tipp noch, ist mir aufgefallen, habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert. Leute meinen, das funktioniert und tut das, was es verspricht. startpage.com ist ein Anonymizer für Google.
Kanntest du noch nicht?
Nein. Gibt es wahrscheinlich schon ewig, aber ist bisher immer komplett an mir vorbeigegangen. Wie lange kennst du das schon? Wie lange gibt es das?
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher. Ich glaube, seit ein oder zwei Jahren kenne ich das.
Ja, ich will auch gar nicht behaupten, dass es neu ist. Ich sage nur, dass es gibt. Mir ist das bisher noch nicht über den Weg gelaufen, warum auch immer. Das ist quasi nichts anderes als ein Frontend vor Google. Das heißt, man gibt Suchbegriffe ein und sie behaupten, dass sie das anonymisieren. Ob sie das dann tatsächlich tun, weiß ich nicht. Oder ob das auch nur so ein Honeypot ist, kann man ja vielleicht mal anschauen und sich eine eigene Meinung bilden. Einfach startpages.com und schon wird anonym rumgegoogelt. Ich selber benutze ja, mobil benutze ich eigentlich nur DuckDuckGo, weil ich das mal so eingestellt habe und das ist so. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin ganz zufrieden mit DuckDuckGo und gehe eigentlich nur dann auf Google, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass die Ente nicht liefert.
Dann gehe ich auf startpage.
Das habe ich auch mal gemacht, aber dann vergesse ich auch immer wieder zurückzugehen.
Also ehrlich gesagt hatte ich zu oft das Gefühl, dass die Ente nicht liefert und bin jetzt wieder bei Google.
Ich suche nur noch über die Ente. Also schon allein auch die ganzen netten Features, mit denen wenn du so ein Shichi suchst, dass du das gleich erst mal präsentiert bekommst und denkst so, danke, das was Hacker wollen. Also ich mein, es ist eine schöne Suchmaschine geworden.
Ja, ich find auch. Also DuckDuckGo ist einfach eine geile Suchmaschine.
Die sind nett. Aber Google hat Vorteile, vor allem bei der Bildersuche. Also da geh ich eigentlich, also Bildersuche find ich, ist Google ungeschlagen.
Achso, eigentlich beim Stackoverflow Programming auch.
Das stimmt, da hat die Ente Nachteile.
Sucht nicht genug. Wenn es so darum geht, jetzt wird nicht so die Fehlermeldung komplett und so.
Nee, das geht, aber wenn man so irgendwie, ja vielleicht sollte man häufiger auf die Suche, auf Stackoverflow benutzen und nicht über eine Suchmaschine suchen.
Naja, aber Google findet halt manchmal auch so Podcasts, soll ich schon sagen, so, Posts aller Art, wo halt auch wichtige Informationen drin sind. Muss ja nicht immer Stackoverflow sein.
Ja, aber das Startpage deine Stärke auf jeden Fall bei der Bildersuche hat, war auch so das, warum ich dann angefangen habe, wenn ich auf der Ente nicht weitergekommen bin, das Startpage zu benutzen.
Ich sag jetzt mal Schluss, weil jetzt ist unsere Zeit rum.
Ja, wir haben auch wirklich alle Themen durch.
Wir haben nahezu alles.
Ein Novum. Wir haben 177 Sendungen gebraucht, um den Themenlisten zu entschöpfen.
Na eins hätt ich noch gehabt, aber da.
Verschieben wir aufs nächste Mal.
Das macht nur Sinn mit Clemens. Auch das ganze Feedback und Wedern-Gefrage, was so ein Kommentar noch aufkam. Wenn er mal wieder da ist, war er aber nicht. Aber Letty war da und Roddy war da, Dennis war da. Und das funktioniert auch ganz gut. Und ich war auch dabei und ihr wart auch dabei. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei der Freak Show. Und jetzt kommt das, was ihr schon denkt, nämlich irgendeine Fehlbedienung. Haben wir noch ein letztes Wort?
Guten Tag.